Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Tom, does it ever strike you that some of our listeners may be driving along, going somewhere for Christmas? Driving home for Christmas. Driving home for Christmas, very nice. Listening to this podcast and thinking to themselves, my partner loves this podcast,
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。汤姆，你有没有想过，我们的某些听众可能正开着车，在去某个地方过圣诞的路上？开车回家过圣诞。开车回家过圣诞，非常不错。听着这个播客，心里想着，我的另一半太喜欢这个播客了，
but I haven't got them anything for Christmas yet. What can I do? And I don't know what to do. Do you have an answer? Can you help these people? Well, I have an amazing announcement to make, which will end, what am I going to get my Restless History
但是我还没给他/她买圣诞礼物呢。我能做点什么？我不知道该怎么办。你有什么答案吗？你能帮帮这些人吗？好吧，我有一个惊人的消息要宣布，这将结束“我到底该给那个热爱《历史余音》的
loving partner for Christmas, Misery? Because what you can do is you can go to restlesshistorypod.com and there, under gifts, you can purchase your loved one a membership of the Restless History Club.
另一半买什么圣诞礼物”的痛苦？因为你能做的是，你可以访问 restlesshistorypod.com，在那里，在“礼物”（gifts）栏目下，你可以为你爱的人购买一份《历史余音》俱乐部的会员资格。
And you can do that right up to Christmas, can't you? It's not like it won't get delivered. I mean, it will get delivered. Dominic, this is the amazing thing. Not only can you do it right up to Christmas, but you can specify that it gets delivered to your loved one on Christmas Day. By Father Christmas. It couldn't be more festive. That's incredible.
而且你一直到圣诞节都可以买，对吧？又不是说不会送到。我的意思是，它肯定能送到。多米尼克，这才是神奇的地方。你不仅可以在圣诞节前夕随时购买，还可以指定它在圣诞节当天送给你爱的人。由圣诞老人亲自送达。没有比这更有节日气氛的了。太不可思议了。
And what do you get as a result of this? You get an incredible array of bargains and benefits. Do you like that? Well, maybe you'd like to list them, Dominic. You've forgotten, clearly. So you get to listen to the rest is history and no ads. You get a bonus episode, Tom. You get a bonus episode.
而作为结果，你能得到什么呢？你会得到一系列令人难以置信的优惠和福利。你喜欢这个吗？好吧，也许你想列举一下，多米尼克。你显然已经忘光了。所以你可以收听无广告的《历史余音》。你会得到一集加更节目，汤姆。你会得到一集加更节目。
You get a bonus episode every week. Every week. And if you sign up to become one of the Athelstan members. Oh, no, but also, Dominic, you get a live episode once every month. Once every month. We just did the 60s, in which I did a brilliant impression of Bob Dylan. Yeah, and the people won't get that if they don't sign up to the club. But if you sign up to become an Athelstan member,
你每周都会得到一集加更节目。每周。如果你注册成为埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）会员。哦，不对，还有，多米尼克，你每个月还能看一次直播节目。每个月。我们刚做了关于60年代的直播，我在里面对鲍勃·迪伦进行了精彩的模仿。对，如果人们不加入俱乐部，就看不到这个。但如果你注册成为埃塞尔斯坦会员，
you get a party. You get a party and you get a personalised message from us. Yeah, you get personalised messages, parties, you get all kinds of treats. It's just insane value. Perks. Yeah. And it's what...
你会得到一场派对。你会得到一场派对，还会收到我们给你的个性化留言。对，你会得到个性化留言、派对，你会得到各种各样的款待。这简直是疯狂划算的福利。特权。对。而且这就是……
So the ordinary membership, am I right in thinking it's only £6 a month? Only £6 a month. Incredible. Absolutely incredible. I think we're basically giving it away. Well, anyway, that's Christmas. Sorted.
那么普通会员资格，我没记错的话，一个月只要6英镑？一个月只要6英镑。难以置信。绝对难以置信。我觉得我们基本上是在白送。好吧，不管怎样，圣诞节的事情。搞定。
Yeah, sorted. It is. It's Christmas. I mean, effectively a gift wrap for you. So don't delay. Go to restishistorypod.com. If you've got a membership already, buy another. Or buy them for neighbours and people at work and stuff.
对，搞定了。没错。这就是圣诞节。我的意思是，实际上就相当于为你准备的礼品包装。所以不要拖延。访问 restishistorypod.com。如果你已经有会员了，再买一个。或者买给邻居、同事之类的人。
Or possibly for passing chimney sweeps. Yeah, exactly. Urchins. Lean out of the window and buy them for neighbours and people possibly for passing chimney suites yeah exactly urchins lean out of the window and buy them all membership don't bother with turkeys buy the membership of the rest is history it'll be the best christmas ever god bless us everyone Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History and the second of our two festive episodes. Dominic, in the first episode, it was all about, it was all the Christmas carol. But for this second one, as a top historian of modern Britain, you would confirm, would you you not that it is very much a tradition that uh popular formats when it comes to christmas kind of put a bit of holly on a bit of sprinkling of snow and give it a festive spin they do they might go to marbella for a
或者可能是给路过的烟囱清扫工。对，没错。顽童。探出窗外，买下它们……或者可能是给路过的烟囱清扫工。对，没错。顽童。探出窗外，把它们全买成会员。别理什么火鸡了，买《历史余音》的会员资格吧。这将是有史以来最好的圣诞节，上帝保佑我们每一个人。哈喽，欢迎收听《历史余音》以及我们两集节日特辑中的第二集。多米尼克，在第一集里，全都是关于圣诞颂歌的内容。但对于这第二集，作为现代英国的顶尖历史学家，你会证实，当圣诞节来临时，一个非常普遍的传统是——呃，那些热门栏目会在圣诞节时挂上一些冬青，撒上一点雪花，赋予它节日特色，对吧？是的，他们可能会去马尔韦拉过
christmas special exactly that kind of thing or florida or something like that but we're not going to do that because one of one of the popular formats that we've had this year is uh top tens so we've had top 10 eunuchs we've had top 10 mistresses we've had all kinds of things like that but i think it would be fair to say that probably that the most popular episode that we did with that top 10 format was with Rachel Morley, who runs the charity Friends of Friendless Churches. And she did the top 10 British churches. She did. And actually, you know what? Tom Christmas is about family.
圣诞特别节目，正是那种类型的节目。或者去佛罗里达之类的。但我们不会那样做，因为我们今年推出的热门栏目之一，呃，就是十佳榜单（top tens）。所以我们有十佳太监榜，十佳情妇榜，我们有各种各样这样的榜单。但我觉得可以说，我们在十佳榜单中做过的最受欢迎的一期节目，大概就是和蕾切尔·莫利（Rachel Morley）一起的那期了，她经营着“无主教堂之友”（Friends of Friendless Churches）慈善机构。她做了英国十佳教堂。她确实做了。而且，你知道吗？汤姆，圣诞节是关于家庭的。
It's about, you know, overlooking the slights and snubs that have piled up over the decades. It's about overlooking all the things that divide you and the hatreds and resentments that have festered for so long. And that's why it's nice for me to have my sister-in-law on the program. Fan favorite. Yes.
是关于，你知道的，放下几十年来积聚的轻视和冷落。是关于放下所有分化你们的事情，以及那些 festered（长期积压）了如此之久的仇恨和怨恨。这就是为什么节目里能有我的小姨子，我感到很高兴。粉丝最爱。对。
So we can again pretend to bury the hatchet for the next hour. And actually, Rachel's coming to us for Christmas Day. Are you still planning to come to us for Christmas Day? I'm coming to you for Christmas Day. I've actually spent the last 10 Christmases with Dominic Sandbrook. So there you go. Oh my God. Is that true? Yeah. That's a terrifying fact. I know. We do our own little podcasts on Christmas Day. Yeah. How exciting. But actually, from our point of view, the excitement of this episode is that, Rachel, we set you the challenge that you had to give us your top 10 British churches in the space of an hour. And I think it's fair to say that...
所以我们可以再次在接下来的一小时里假装言归于好了。事实上，蕾切尔要来和我们一起过圣诞节。你还计划来和我们一起过圣诞节吗？我要来和你们一起过圣诞节。我实际上已经和多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）一起度过了过去的10个圣诞节。所以你看。哦，天哪。真的吗？对。这是一个可怕的事实。我知道。我们在圣诞节那天做我们自己的小播客。对。多令人兴奋啊。但实际上，从我们的角度来看，这期节目最让人兴奋的是，蕾切尔，我们给你出个挑战，你必须在一小时内给出你的英国十佳教堂。我觉得可以说……
I did it. Fine. You just, well, kind of, kind of. Time management is not on your LinkedIn page. But it was very, very exciting. And so basically, you've very kindly agreed to come back. And we're going to replay that with your top 10 festive British churches. Christmas churches. How exciting. Christmas churches. The churches that have the most kind of festive connotations. And again, we're going to see if we can do it within an hour.
我做到了。好吧。你只是，嗯，算是吧，算是吧。时间管理可不在你的领英（LinkedIn）主页上。但这是非常非常令人兴奋的。所以基本上，你非常友善地同意回来了。我们将重温那一期，带上你评选的英国节日十佳教堂。圣诞教堂。多令人兴奋。圣诞教堂。那些最具节日色彩联想的教堂。同样，我们要看看我们能不能在一小时内搞定。
OK, let's try it. Stop talking. Let's go. Yeah, enough flam. Let's get on. Well, I thought of something, actually. We. Enough flam. Let's get on. Well, I thought of something, actually. We should just say Christmas is a time of giving, Tom. And if there's a charity that you would like to give to this Christmas, apart from just don't engineer hedgehogs and all that stuff, which charity will you be donating to? Well, I've already mentioned it.
好的，我们试试。别说话了。开始吧。对，废话少说。我们开始吧。嗯，我其实想到了点什么。我们……废话少说。我们开始吧。嗯，我其实想到了点什么。我们应该说，圣诞节是一个给予的季节，汤姆。如果在今年圣诞节你想捐款给某个慈善机构，除了那些“别去残害刺猬”之类的事情之外，你会把钱捐给哪个慈善机构呢？好吧，我刚才已经提到了。
Friends of Friendless Churches. Yes. Don't donate to rival church charities. Donate to the Friends of Friendless Churches. Okay. Promotion over. Rachel, go. Okay, great. Fine. don't donate to rival church charities donate to the friends of friendless churches okay promotion over rachel go okay great uh fine so it is my top 10 christmas churches uh i would probably say top tenuous christmas churches so kind of ten tenuous tenuous yeah that's very good it's supposed to be a joke come on that's top's top quality. Great. Thanks. Fine.
“无主教堂之友”。对。不要捐给那些竞争对手的教堂慈善机构。要捐给“无主教堂之友”。好了。宣传结束。蕾切尔，请继续。好的，太棒了。行。不要捐给那些竞争对手的教堂慈善机构，要捐给“无主教堂之友”。好了。宣传结束。蕾切尔，请继续。好的，太棒了，呃，好吧。所以这是我的圣诞教堂十佳榜单……我大概可以说这是“勉强沾边的圣诞教堂十佳榜单”吧——所以有点牵强，牵强，对，这非常好。这本来就是个笑话，得了吧，这可是顶级水准。太棒了。谢谢。行吧。
Anyway. Okay. I'll get straight into it. So the first thing is, let's face it. So at Christmas time, that is when most people go to church, right? I mean, really. Even the statistics tell us that. And it's mainly all about candles and singing and all of that.
不管怎样。好吧。我直接切入正题。所以第一点是，咱们面对现实吧。在圣诞节期间，那是大多数人去教堂的时候，对吧？我是说，真的。连统计数据都告诉我们这一点。而且这基本上全都是关于蜡烛、歌唱和所有这些。
The music is, you know, it's kind of, it's dark and light. It's the wonder and the awe and the kind of sombre and joyousness of it all. It's the birth of our saviour. But as you're out there and you're singing along to Handel or Hayden, I think it's important to remember that these men themselves weren't saints themselves. So Hayden, for example, he wrote Masses for Advent. He was expelled from St Stephen's Church Choir in Vienna for cutting off the pigtails of the other choristers. That's bad.
音乐呢，你知道的，它有点……它有黑暗也有光明。它是其中的惊奇、敬畏，以及那种庄严与欢乐的交织。它是我们救世主的诞生。但当你在那里跟着亨德尔（Handel）或海顿（Haydn）的音乐一起歌唱时，我认为重要的是要记住，这些人本身并不是圣人。以海顿为例，他写过降临节弥撒曲。他曾因剪掉维也纳圣史蒂芬教堂合唱团其他成员的辫子而被开除。这太糟了。
It is pretty bad. It gets worse. In between his temper tantrums, Handel hid in dark wardrobes and quaffed champagne. He did. In the early 20th century, Peter Warlock, I've just broken my pen, Peter Warlock, who wrote Bethlehem Down,
这确实挺糟的。情况更糟的是。在发脾气之余，亨德尔会躲在黑衣柜里狂饮香槟。他真的这么干过。在20世纪初，彼得·沃洛克（Peter Warlock）——我刚把钢笔弄断了——彼得·沃洛克，他创作了《伯利恒之乡》（Bethlehem Down），
he was famous for these notorious carouses. And one thing he liked to do in particular was disturb the local Baptist chapel by driving around outside naked on his motorbike. Oh my God. Was that a sort of sectarianism? He didn't like Baptists? Or maybe he just liked being naked on a motorbike.
他以这些臭名昭著的狂欢而闻名。他特别喜欢做的一件事，就是骑着摩托车赤身裸体地在外面绕圈，以此来打扰当地的浸信会教堂。哦，天哪。这是一种宗派主义吗？他不喜欢浸信会？或者他只是喜欢骑摩托车时赤身裸体？
I don't know. Quite cold though at Christmas, wasn't it? Very cold. Yeah, I don't know. If you have at Christmas, wouldn't it? Very cold. Yeah, I don't know. If you have an accident, it's a hard one to explain to the emergency services. Yeah, exactly. But for me, best of all, is Thomas Weeks.
我不知道。不过圣诞节的时候挺冷的，不是吗？非常冷。对，我不知道。如果在圣诞节发生事故，这也是个很难向紧急服务部门解释的事故。对， exatamente（没错）。但对我来说，最棒的是托马斯·威克斯（Thomas Weeks）。
He was the director of music at Chichester Cathedral in the 17th century. And even if we don't know it, we regularly perform his music at Christmas. It's kind of a routine sort of thing. So Hosanna, Son of David, Hark all ye lovely angels above, all this sort of thing. This was all his music. But in the 17th century at Chichester Cathedral, he was fined for urinating on the dean from the organ loft. At Christmas? At Christmas.
他在17世纪担任奇切斯特大教堂（Chichester Cathedral）的音乐总监。即使我们不知道，我们在圣诞节时也经常演奏他的音乐。这是一种常规的事情。比如《和散那，大卫之子》（Hosanna, Son of David），《听啊，所有上面可爱的天使》（Hark all ye lovely angels above），诸如此类。这全都是他的音乐。但在17世纪的奇切斯特大教堂，他曾因在管风琴楼上向院长小便而被罚款。在圣诞节？在圣诞节。
And constantly, loudly blaspheming during the services so number one music at Christmas Thomas Weeks Chichester Cathedral I think I think that's a Christmas tradition that should be but I think it's funny he was only fined for it he didn't even lose his job what would he have had to do to... I've lost his job, I know. I should say that that anecdote is particularly... It came from my friend Robert Busiekiewicz, who is a composer in Toronto. So thank you to Robert for that. That's a good one. That's a great anecdote.
而且在礼拜期间不断地大声亵渎神明。所以，排在第一位的是：圣诞节音乐，托马斯·威克斯，奇切斯特大教堂。我认为，我认为这是一个应该被保留的圣诞传统。但我觉得有趣的是，他只是因此被罚款，他甚至都没有失去工作。他得做什么才会……失去工作，我知道。我应该说，那个轶事特别……它来自我在多伦多的作曲家朋友罗伯特·布西基维奇（Robert Busiekiewicz）。所以感谢罗伯特提供这个。这是一个很好的轶事。这是一个很棒的轶事。
And he was allowed to carry on composing, was he? Yeah, no problem at all. Why did he do it? That's the question. Why? Well, I mean, I don't know. The blaspheming does seem weird when you're writing Christmas carols. So he's not like an question. Why? Well, I mean, I don't know. I mean, the blaspheming does seem weird when you're writing Christmas carols. So he's not like an atheist or something. Or a, you know...
而且他被允许继续作曲，是吗？对，完全没问题。他为什么要这么做？这是个问题。为什么？好吧，我的意思是，我不知道。当你创作圣诞颂歌时，亵渎神明确实显得很奇怪。所以他不像是一个……问题。为什么？好吧，我的意思是，我不知道。我的意思是，当你创作圣诞颂歌时，亵渎神明确实显得很奇怪。所以他不像是一个无神论者什么的。或者一个，你知道的……
Is he drunk? What's the motive? Yeah, I'd say probably a drunk. Okay. Yeah, okay. Well, that's also very festive, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. Getting drunk and urinating over a congregation?
他是喝醉了吗？动机是什么？对，我猜大概是个酒鬼吧。好吧。对，好吧。嗯，这也挺有节日气氛的，不是吗？对，没错。喝醉了还在信众头上撒尿？
On top of your team. That's lovely, yeah. It's all part of the festive tapestry. Yeah, yeah. It's all part of the festive tapestry. Yeah, exactly. You've just had your Christmas lunch. You didn't do that at the Friends of Friendless Church's lunch, did you? I did not do that
在你们院长头上。那挺可爱的，对。这都是节日挂毯的一部分。对，对。这都是节日挂毯的一部分。对，没错。你刚吃完圣诞午餐。你没在“无主教堂之友”的午餐上干那事吧？我没有在
at the Friends of Friendless Church's Christmas lunch, no. Although we did have some nice wine, which was good. Okay, good. Thanks. That's good to know. Great, yeah. Anyway, next one.
“无主教堂之友”的圣诞午餐上干那事，没有。虽然我们确实喝了一些不错的好酒，这倒挺好的。好吧，很好。谢谢。很高兴知道这一点。太好了，对。不管怎样，下一个。
So that was the first one. Wow. Number one. That was ridiculously fast by your standards. I know, I know, I know. But there are some long ones. So I thought I'd, you know, I opened it by being, you know, light and dark, you know, fast by your standards. I know, I know, I know. But there are some long ones. So I thought I'd, you know, I opened it by being, you know, light and dark, you know, sombre and joy.
所以那是第一个。哇。第一名。按照你的标准，这也太快了吧。我知道，我知道，我知道。但有些条目很长。所以我想，你知道的，我一开始的表现是，你知道的，有光有影，你知道的，按你的标准来说很快。我知道，我知道，我知道。但有些条目很长。所以我想，你知道的，我一开始的表现是，你知道的，有光有影，有庄严也有欢乐。
So there's long and short. Anyway, there we go. The next one's long. Right. Okay. You opened all of this by talking about giving. Christmas is all about, you know, giving and donations to charity and all. And churches are absolutely about that.
所以有长有短。好吧，就这样。下一个很长。好。好吧。你一开始谈论的是给予。圣诞节全都是关于，你知道的，给予和慈善捐款之类的事情。教堂绝对就是关于这个的。
So there are, you know, benefaction boards. They hang in churches all across the country in life and death. People wanted to donate to their local church, to their local school, the almshouse, or most commonly towards the poor. And, you know, I could be cynical and say that their motives were to guarantee them a place in heaven afterwards, but maybe that's a bit mean and maybe they were just very nice, generous people, but, you know, maybe not. Anyway, but some of these boards make specific reference to Christmas. So one example that I really love is at Holy Trinity Blatherwick in Northamptonshire.
所以，你知道的，有慈善捐赠牌。它们挂在全国各地的教堂里，记录着生与死。人们想要向当地的教堂、当地的学校、济贫院捐款，或者最常见的是捐给穷人。而且，你知道的，我可以冷嘲热讽地说，他们的动机是为了保证自己死后能在天堂占有一席之地，但也许这话有点刻薄，也许他们只是非常好、非常慷慨的人，但，你知道的，也许并不是。不管怎样，但其中一些牌匾明确提到了圣诞节。所以我真的很喜欢的一个例子是在北安普顿郡布拉瑟威克的圣三一教堂（Holy Trinity Blatherwick）。
And here, Mr. Thomas Coles, who died in the year 1684, he left a sum of money, which was forever to buy a plum pudding for the oldest poor men in the parish on Christmas Day. Isn't that nice? That is. That's kind of scrooge-esque it is lovely and do they still do that no oh that's one of the things because like forever is a pretty like loose term i think but equally equally um another christmas one which is not far from you dominic in south lee and oxfordshire i know you don't at all. Don't be funny. That's what I ask. You don't know. Dominic, do you know it? Are you lying?
在这里，托马斯·科尔斯先生（Mr. Thomas Coles）于1684年去世，他留下了一笔钱，永远用来在圣诞节那天为教区最年长的穷人买一个圣诞布丁。这不是很棒吗？确实。这有点像狄更斯笔下的吝啬鬼，但真的很可爱。他们现在还在这样做吗？没有。哦，这就是其中一件事，因为“永远”这个词在某种程度上是个相当宽松的词，我想，但同样地，同样地，嗯……另一个圣诞节的例子离你很近，多米尼克，在牛津郡的索利（South Leigh），我知道你根本不知道。别开玩笑了。我才问呢。你不知道。多米尼克，你知道吗？你在撒谎吗？
I've seen it on road signs. I don't know the church. I mean, of course I don't know the church. Anyway, there's a lovely church there called St. James's. Lovely place. But in there, there's a benefaction board in the North Isle and in it, again in the 17th century, John Hart left £50
我在路标上看到过。我不知道这座教堂。我的意思是，我当然不知道这座教堂。不管怎样，那里有一座可爱的教堂叫圣詹姆斯教堂（St. James's）。很可爱的地方。但在那里，北走廊里有一块慈善捐赠牌，上面记录着，同样是在17世纪，约翰·哈特（John Hart）留下了50英镑，
intended for it to gather interest to buy coats at Christmas for the parish poor forever. That's nice. I was taught by a man
旨在通过赚取利息，永远在圣诞节为教区的穷人购买大衣。这挺好的。我曾被一个名叫
called John Hart who was the first ever mastermind winner. Wow. There you go. That's good. Rachel, do we know,
约翰·哈特的人教导过，他是史上第一位智者（Mastermind）智力竞赛节目的冠军。哇。你看。这挺好的。蕾切尔，我们知道，
is this request still going or is that being cancelled as well? All cancelled. All over. That's a shame. Yeah, I think, yeah, it's interesting because a lot of these so anyway a lot of these things they do say forever and uh yeah how can the church get out of that though i mean well the money just runs out you know right yeah bad investments yeah invested in the south sea bubble or something yeah exactly yeah exactly. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Northern rock.
这个请求现在还在继续吗，还是也被取消了？全取消了。全结束了。那太遗憾了。对，我觉得，对，这很有趣，因为其中很多事情——所以无论如何，很多事情它们确实说的是“永远”，呃……不过教堂怎么能摆脱这个呢？我的意思是——好吧，钱就是会用光，你知道的，对吧？是的，糟糕的投资。是的，投资了南海泡沫（South Sea Bubble）什么的。对，没错，对，没错。北方岩石银行（Northern Rock）。
So while, you know, the plum pudding and the coat at Christmas, those sorts of things were all, you know, those are all lovely. Some of the charity was conditional. So one of the churches that we look after is St. Elu's Llanelliw in Powys in the Black Mountains. Stop laughing, Dominic. didn't stop laughing dominic um and in 1773 walter watkins left 10 shillings to be given to two of the poorest children in the parish yearly and forever but there was one condition they could only be lawfully begot so okay so is that a problem in wales rage what are you trying to say no i'm not saying that it's a problem in Wales, Dominic. I'm saying that, you know, it was conditional.
所以，尽管，你知道的，圣诞布丁和圣诞大衣，那些事情都很好，那些都很可爱。但有些慈善是有条件的。所以我们照顾的其中一座教堂是波伊斯（Powys）黑山（Black Mountains）的拉内利夫圣埃卢教堂（St. Elu's Llanelliw）。别笑了，多米尼克。别笑了，多米尼克。而且在1773年，沃尔特·沃特金斯（Walter Watkins）留下了10先令，每年且永远分发给教区里两个最穷的孩子。但有一个条件：他们必须是合法出生的。好吧，所以这是威尔士的一个问题吗，蕾切尔？你想说什么？不，我不是说这是威尔士的一个问题，多米尼克。我是说，你知道的，这是有条件的。
He didn't care whether they were very poor. Because arguably the illegally begot, unlawfully begot, would require them. Correct, correct, correct, correct. Yes, exactly. Anyway, but the tradition of giving in churches is more than just all those individuals that are memorialised on these benefaction boards. And most churches had poor boxes or alms boxes, and most of them were inscribed urging passersby to remember the poor. And really, for centuries, these poor boxes were society's main source of poor relief. So two of the earliest poor boxes in Englandland um date from the mid-14th
他才不在乎他们是不是非常穷呢。因为可以说，那些非婚生的、不合法出生的孩子，才更需要这些。没错，没错，没错，没错。是的，正好。不管怎样，但是在教堂里的给予传统，不仅仅是那些被刻在这些慈善捐赠牌上的个人。大多数教堂都有募捐箱或救济金箱，其中大多数上面都刻着铭文，敦促路人不要忘记穷人。真的，几个世纪以来，这些募捐箱一直是社会救济穷人的主要来源。所以英格兰最古老的两个募捐箱……可以追溯到14世纪中叶，
century and they're still found on holy island on northumberland but most yeah there you go tom great yeah but most of the surviving ones uh which are still in use date from the 17th century so from here this is chris this is where the christmasy bit comes in again so uh boxing day it's been a tradition in the UK for centuries. And though it only officially got that name in the 1830s and it didn't become a bank holiday until the 1870s, it is celebrated on 26th of December, the feast day of St Stephen.
现在还能在诺森伯兰郡的圣岛（Holy Island）上找到。但大多数——是的，没错，汤姆，太棒了——但大多数幸存的、仍在使用的募捐箱，可以追溯到17世纪。所以从这里开始，这就是……这就是又跟圣诞节沾边的地方了。所以，节礼日（Boxing Day）在英国已经有几个世纪的传统了。虽然它直到1830年代才正式获得这个名字，直到1870年代才成为银行假日，但它是在12月26日庆祝的，也就是圣史蒂芬日（feast day of St Stephen）。
And he was an early deacon who was charged with taking care of the poor. That was his thing. He got stoned, didn't he? Huh? Stoned to death. He did, yeah. Christian martyr. Exactly. But the 26th of December, that's fine. The 26th of December was the day that the rich boxed up
他是一位早期的执事，负责照顾穷人。这就是他的职责。他被用石头砸死了，对吧？啊？被石头砸死。是的，他确实是。基督教殉道者。没错。但是12月26日，这很好。12月26日是富人们把
these gifts for the poor of the parish. And it was also a day off for servants when they received a gift box for their Christmas gift box from their employers. And in turn, they would meet their families and they would exchange boxes. So it was like, you know, Christmas, Boxinging Day thing but churches played a really important role in this Boxing Day tradition so coins that were collected in these alms boxes throughout the year were held in the box and it was opened on Christmas Day and then on the following day Boxing Day the money was
这些礼物打包送给教区穷人的日子。这也是仆人们的休息日，他们会从雇主那里收到一份圣诞礼物盒。反过来，他们会去见家人并交换盒子。所以这就好像是，你知道的，圣诞节、节礼日的活动。但教堂在这个节礼日传统中扮演了非常重要的角色：一年中收集在这些救济金箱里的硬币被保存在箱子里，在圣诞节那天打开，然后在接下来的那一天——节礼日——钱被
taken out and distributed to the poor so isn't that lovely so some of these alms boxes are really cool and some of my favorite ones are in Norfolk. And they kind of, I have a thing for donation boxes. I have an Instagram page called Church Donation Boxes, if anybody would like to follow me, where I take pictures of donation boxes in churches. But I really like them. But there's some really interesting ones.
取出来分发给穷人。所以这不是很可爱吗？所以其中一些救济金箱真的很酷，我最喜欢的一些在诺福克郡（Norfolk）。我对募捐箱有一种特殊的情结。我有一个名为“教堂募捐箱”（Church Donation Boxes）的Instagram账号，如果有人想关注我的话，我会在上面拍摄教堂里募捐箱的照片。我真的很喜欢它们。这里有一些非常有趣的。
And there's my number one, number whatever, two, carved is, it's Watton Church in Norfolk and it's this little guy and he's got like it's a little man and he's carved and his hair is kind of all like straight lines
我的第一名，或者随便第几名吧，雕刻的是诺福克的沃顿教堂（Watton Church）。这是一个小家伙，他长得像……这是一个小人，他是雕刻出来的，他的头发有点像……全都是那种直线，
streaky down and he's got a little sorry you can't see me he's got a little hand out like this and you put the coin into his hand and then it drops down
一缕一缕向下的。他有一只小手——抱歉，你们看不到我——他有一只小手像这样伸着，你把硬币放进他的手里，然后硬币就会掉下来，
into a little bag and into the core of the money box and I love that it's such how old is that? 17th century. And is he almost like a little gnome kind of
掉进一个小袋子里，落入钱箱的核心部位。我太喜欢了，这真是……这个有多久的历史了？17世纪。他是不是有点像一个小侏儒似的人物，蕾切尔？不，他没有滑稽的帽子和胡子之类。但你知道的，他就像是一个有点滑稽的人物。他是吗？还是说他是个严肃的人物？我的意思是，他看起来真的很开心、很高兴，伸出他的手好像在说：“哦，往我手里放个硬币吧”那种感觉。但我真的很喜欢，
figure, Rach? No, like he doesn't have a funny hat and beard and stuff like that. But you know, he's like a sort of comical figure. Is he or is he a serious figure? I mean, he looks really happy and jolly and like with his hand out like, oh, put a coin in my hand sort of thing. But I love it
你可以看到他手上的磨损，因为硬币从他手上划过……就像“哦，往我手里放个硬币吧”那种感觉，你知道的。但我真的很喜欢，你可以看到他手上的磨损，因为硬币从他手上划过，就像你知道的那样，所有的漆都差不多剥落了，木头也差不多被磨损了，
and you can see all the wear kind of from where the coin went on his hand, like oh put a coin in my hand sort of thing you know but I love it and you can see all the wear kind of from where the coin went on his hand like you know where all the paint is sort of chipped and the wood is kind of gnawed and stuff
所以我很喜欢这样。所以无论如何，募捐箱，募捐箱真的很酷，是圣诞节的巨大组成部分，是节礼日的巨大组成部分。
so I love that so anyway boxes donation boxes donation boxes are really cool huge part of Christmas huge part of Boxing Day
在诺福克的沃顿能找到一个非常棒的募捐箱。非常好。所以那是第二名。那是第二名。太棒了。好吧，我们应该试着找一张那东西的照片，
a brilliant one to be found in Watton in Norfolk very good so that's number two that's number two brilliant okay so we should try and find a photograph of that
然后把它发出来。是的，蕾切尔，你会给我们发推特照片和所有这些东西吗？我会的，当然，没问题，好的。
and put that up yeah Rachel will you tweet us pictures and all that sort of stuff I will sure yeah that's fine no problem okay
准备好了吗？是的。第三名。好吧，第三名。当我们临近圣诞节时，我和许多其他人
are you ready yeah number three okay number three as we approach Christmas I and many other people
总是会想起M·R·詹姆斯（M.R. James）。是的，非常好，蕾切尔。我让你这么做了。我知道你这么做了。多米尼克，我本来就要告诉大家的。就算你不说……就算你没告诉我，我也会说的。那是谎言，汤姆。那不是真的。虽然
always think of M.R. James yes very good Rachel I told you to do this. I know you did. Dominic, I was supposed to tell people. I would have done it if you... I would have done it even if you didn't tell me. That's a lie, Tom. That is not true. Although
我要说的是，我必须把我对M·R·詹姆斯的喜爱完全归功于多米尼克，因为在多米尼克开始给我看一些鬼故事并把我吓得半死之前，我从来没听说过他。他确实这么做了。汤姆，在蕾切尔还很小的时候，我和我太太带她去伦敦看过一场名为《鬼故事》（Ghost Stories）的戏剧。那是个惊喜，
I will say that I have to credit my love of M.R. James completely to Dominic because I'd never heard of him until he started showing me some ghost stories and frightening the life out of me. He did. We took Rachel when she was quite young, Tom, to a play in London called Ghost Stories, my wife and I. And it was a surprise,
对吧，蕾切尔？就像是一个惊喜款待。我们拐过街角，他们看到了剧院的正面，上面写着《鬼故事》。蕾切尔的脸像石头一样垮了下来。就像血色全无一样。因为你非常容易被吓到。
wasn't it, Rach? It was like a surprise treat. And we went around the corner and they saw the front of the theatre and it said Ghost Stories. And Rachel's face fell like a stone. It was like the blood drained. Because you're very easily spooked.
我非常容易被吓到。这些是根据M·R·詹姆斯的作品改编的吗？不是。它们是根据……它们是根据角色扮演改编的吗？因为M·R·詹姆斯，我们应该说一下，对吧？是的，抱歉。M·R·詹姆斯。
I'm very easily spooked. Were these based on M.R. James? No. They were based on... Were they based on like role-playing? on M.R. James? No. They were based on... Were they based on like... Because M.R. James, we should say, shouldn't we? Yeah, sorry. M.R. James.
说吧，汤姆。告诉我们M·R·詹姆斯是谁。我能说。好吧。对，你是嘉宾。我是嘉宾。对，谢谢。而且我有笔记，
Go on, Tom. Tell us who M.R. James is. I can tell you. All right. Yeah, you're the guest. I'm the guest. Yeah, thanks. And I've got the notes,
所以我最好还是，你知道的，用一下。所以，好吧。M·R·詹姆斯，他是剑桥大学国王学院（King's College, Cambridge）的院长（dean）和教务长（provost）。他是剑桥大学的副校长。……他是剑桥大学国王学院的院长和教务长。他是剑桥大学的副校长。他是世界上研究手稿最杰出的学者之一。那是19世纪末、20世纪初的时候。那是他进行所有研究的时候。
so I might as well, you know, use them. So, okay. M.R. James, he was a dean and provost of King's College, Cambridge. He was the vice-chancellor of Cambridge University., he was a dean and provost of King's College, Cambridge. He was the vice chancellor of Cambridge University. And he was one of the most distinguished scholars in the world for his work on manuscripts. And it was kind of late 19th, early 20th century. That's when he was doing all his work.
但真正让他被铭记的，是他的鬼故事。他在国王学院期间开始创作这些鬼故事，在教堂的平安夜礼拜结束后，他会邀请一群精选的学生、他的朋友、他的同事回到他的房间，听他写的一个鬼故事。这就是M·R·詹姆斯。他的故事总是关于一些古物学家，他们去教堂和建筑里发掘奇怪的东西。
But really, it's for his ghost stories that he's best remembered. And he started writing these ghost stories while he was at King's and after Christmas Eve services at the chapel, he would invite a group of, a select group of students, his friends, his colleagues, back to his room to hear one of these ghost stories that he had written. So that is M.R. James. And they're always about kind of antiquarians who go and uncover strange things in churches and buildings.
有点像是找到哨子之类的小玩意。对，然后他们解开了诅咒，接着就会听到门上有抓挠声，或者风景中出现一个人影。正是如此。所以在M·R·詹姆斯的《鬼故事全集》中，达里尔·琼斯（Daryl Jones）写了这篇导言，我认为他用最简练的方式对詹姆斯的风格进行了非常精彩的总结。
Kind of find whistles and things. Right, and then they unleash a curse and then there's like a scratching at the door or a figure on the landscape. Exactly. So in the collected ghost stories of M.R. James, Daryl Jones has written this introduction and I think he writes the most succinct kind of summary
所以他说：在典型的M·R·詹姆斯故事中，一个单身大学教师（don）或古物学者发现了一份丢失的手稿或文物，这释放出了超自然力量，迫使他重新思考自己对现实本质的舒适假设。
of James's style kind of really brilliantly. So he says, In a typical M.R. James story, a bachelor don or antiquarian scholar discovers a lost manuscript or artifact which unleashes supernatural forces, causing him to rethink his comfortable assumptions about the nature of reality.
这很好。非常不错。确实如此。所以这基本上就是——这就是几乎每一个M·R·詹姆斯故事的情节。但詹姆斯本人就是这样的人，因为他本人在1900年代初期发现了一个手稿残片，这促成了对伯里圣埃德蒙兹（Bury St. Edmunds）修道院废墟的大规模发掘。这促成了对12世纪修道院院长墓穴的发现，这些墓穴自从解散（dissolution）以来就一直下落不明。所以，你知道的，所以他其实是在亲身过着这种生活，真的。他就是这个单身大学教师，你知道的，古物学者。他就是这样的人。所以，你知道的，很多内容其实都有自传性质。我最喜欢的爱德华·詹姆斯（Edward James）的故事是《阿美特巴斯的宝藏》（The Treasure of Abbot Thomas）——汤姆，你不知道。
That's good. Very good. It is. So that is basically like, that is the plot of nearly every single M.R. James story. But James himself is sort of this person because he himself, in the early 1900s, discovered a manuscript fragment that led to extensive excavation at the Abbey ruins in Bury St. Edmunds. And it led to the discovery of 12th century graves of 12th century abbots
多米尼克，你觉得这很好。好吧，我可能知道。提醒我一下。我相信我会想起来的。这是一个中世纪历史学者。他给一个牧师讲了一个故事：他在一个修道院图书馆里搜寻，找到了指引他寻找这个声誉扫地的修道院院长隐藏宝藏的线索。基本上，他在彩色玻璃中发现了一个密码，它引导着他，告诉他宝藏藏在哪里。
that had been lost since the dissolution. So, you know, so he was, you know, so he was actually kind of living this life himself, really. He was this bachelor, Don, you know, antiquarian scholar. He was this person. So he's, you know, a lot of it is kind of autobiographical. My favourite Edward James story is The Treasure of Amethabas. Tom, you don't know it.
太酷了。就像，我太喜欢了。我喜欢那种，你知道的，破译所有密码之类的事情。但我在开头说过，你知道的，其中很大一部分是有自传性质的。所以M·R·詹姆斯实际上就是这个故事中的学者。他当时正在为德国施泰因费尔德修道院（Steinfeld Abbey）的玻璃进行编目，因此在该修道院解散时，许多16世纪的玻璃被运到了东盎格利亚（East Anglia），它们存在于许多东盎格利亚的教堂中，但其中很大一部分去了赫特福德郡的阿什里奇庄园（Ashridge House）小教堂，现在很多都在维多利亚与阿尔伯特博物馆（V&A）。但实际上，M·R·詹姆斯就是那个在阿什里奇庄园为这些玻璃编目的人，所以他实际上是在与这些碎片打交道，因此他直接受到了他正在研究的物体的启发。
Dominic, you think it's good. Well, I might do. Remind me of it. I'm sure it will come back. It's a scholar of medieval history. And he tells a rector this tale of he's searching in an Abbey library and he found clues that lead him to the hidden treasure of this disgraced abbot. Basically, he finds a code in the stained glass and it leads him, it tells him where the treasure is hidden.
M·R·詹姆斯在他去世前大约五个月写的最后一个故事叫做《一个小插曲》（A Vignette）。他没有特别提起过，但被认为是他的所有故事中最具有自传性质的一个。它完全是关于一个孩子在他住的牧师住宅花园里看到一个幽灵或怪物的场景。那是在萨福克的格レート·利弗米尔（Great Livermere），也就是他自己长大的地方。詹姆斯，他使用了墓碑上的角色，那些墓碑上的名字……在萨福克的大利弗米尔，他自己就是在那里长大的。詹姆斯在许多故事中都使用了墓碑上的角色、那些墓碑上的名字。所以，有……莫瑟索尔太太（Mrs. Mother Sough），她在《灰树》（The Ash Tree）里；有高迪先生（Mr. Gowdy）在《墨水画》（Mezzotint）里。但詹姆斯本人被安葬在伊顿（Eton）圣约翰公墓（St John's Cemetery）的后面。我真的觉得好难过，因为我觉得他是
And it's so cool. Like, I love that. I love that kind of, you know, the deciphering all the codes and stuff like that but I said at the beginning that you know some so much of it was autobiographical so M.R. James actually is the scholar in this story so he was cataloging the glass from the German abbey at Steinfeld and so upon the dissolution of that abbey a lot of the 16th century glass was brought over to East Anglia, and it's in lots of East Anglian churches, but a huge amount of it went to the chapel at Ashridge House
如此……他的故事是如此受欢迎，如此受人喜爱，而他只有一个简单的小墓碑，上面只写着他是剑桥和伊顿的教务长的日期，
in Hertfordshire, and now a lot of it is in the V&A, but actually M.R. James was the guy who was cataloguing this glass at Ashridge House, so he was actually working with these fragments, so he was directly inspired by the objects he was working with.
除此之外没有任何关于他的工作的内容，而且它完全被淹没在公墓的背面，杂草丛生，
M.R. James's last story that he wrote only about five months before he died is called A Vignette. He didn't especially raise it, but it's thought to be the most kind of autobiographical of all of his stories. And it's all about a child seeing a spectre or a monster in the garden of a rectory that he lives. And that was at Great Livermere in Suffolk, where he grew up himself. James, he used characters from the gravestones, the names on those gravest um at great livermere in suffolk where he grew up himself james he used characters from the gravestones the names on those gravestones at great livermere many of his stories so there's um mrs mother soul she's in the ash tree there's mr gaudy in mezzo tint but james himself is buried at the back of saint john's cemetery in ethan and it's really I find it so sad because I think he's
你真的必须像挖一样在周围找才能找到它。但这不是很贴切吗？很贴切。我刚才也在想同一件事。一座失落的坟墓。我知道。你真的必须知道你在找什么。我知道，但不管怎样，我觉得有点难过，你知道的。好吧，所以那是第三名？
so he's his stories are so popular and so loved and he's just got this simple little headstone that just gives the date that he was a provost
那是第三名，对。哦，天哪，天哪，汤姆。所以……下一个是个长的吗？是的。那我们现在休息一下吧，汤姆。我们应该休息一下。因为接下来，蕾切尔，你有一个巨大的挑战，你必须在半小时内讲完七个。和之前一样的悬念。
at Cambridge and Eton and nothing about you know anything other of his work and it's lost at the back of the cemetery completely overgrown
完全是一样的故事。对，这非常令人兴奋。我们一开始太快活了。我们应该浪费一些时间。我不认为听众会觉得这是在浪费时间。我想他们会觉得这些时间没有白花。不，我觉得这是一个中肯的观点。但这绝对是一种节日悬念。
and you really have to like dig your way around to find it. But that's quite fitting, isn't it? It is fitting. I was just thinking the same thing. A lost tomb. I know. You really have to know what you're looking for. I know, but anyway, I feel like it's a bit sad that, you know. Okay, so is that number three?
好了，我们开始播广告吧。所以我们要播广告了。我们快点把这个做完，然后我们来看看这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
That's number three, yeah. Oh my god, good god, Tom. So... Is the next one a long one? Yeah. Let's take a break now then, Tom. We should take a break then. Because then, Rachel, you've got a massive challenge that you've got to get seven in half an hour. Same jeopardy as before.
欢迎回到《历史余音》。现在，到了每周这个时候，我们喜欢谈论我们在在线杂志《UnHerd》上的朋友们。U-N-H-E-R-D。也就是 unheard.com。对。他们一如既往地反抗羊群心态（herd mentality），鼓励独立思考。
It's exactly the same story. Yeah, it is very exciting. We were being too jovial at the beginning. We should have wasted time. I don't think the listeners will think it was a waste. I think they'll think it was time well spent. No, I think that's a fair point. But it's definitely kind of festive jeopardy.
汤姆，你知道 UnHerd 这周的网站上有什么吗？我知道，多米尼克。有一篇非常棒的文章，作者是吉尔斯·弗雷泽（Giles Fraser）牧师，他是英国最顶级的牧师之一，题目叫《世俗圣诞节是个谎言》。你知道他是怎么说的吗？好吧，听起来口气很强硬。
Okay, let's get on with the ad. So we'll get on with the ad. We'll do this very quickly, and then we'll see you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
他说什么了？他说，只有对其基督教的理解才说得通，我完全同意这一点。是的。你怎么会不喜欢这篇文章？好吧，你知道我其实挺喜欢的——我去年为 UnHerd 写过一篇，题目就叫《异教圣诞节的神话》。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, it's that time of the week when we like to talk about our friends at the online magazine UnHerd. U-N-H-E-R-D. That's unheard.com. Yeah. Pushing back, as they always are, against herd mentality and encouraging independent thinking.
哦，天哪，你可别告诉我吉尔斯·弗雷泽踩到你的尾巴了。不，我没有……我不认为一个牧师……我是说，我是在踩牧师的尾巴，但这是一个略有不同的视角。所以我的视角是，你知道的，我们在关于异教的节目中与罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）讨论过的那个论点——圣诞节是对原始异教节日的一种基督教改造的观点——我对此提出了质疑。所以，对，你完全不同意那种看法，是吗？不，那绝对是我的观点。吉尔斯·弗雷泽显然不是这么想的。所以听着，我知道大家应该怎么做。我觉得很多人应该……
And, Tom, do you know what UnHerd have on their website this week? I do, Dominic. There's an excellent article by the Reverend Giles Fraser, one of Britain's very topmost vicars, called Secular Christmas is a Lie. And do you know what he says? Well, that sounds very strong.
……这里写着“赠送”（gift）。我不把“赠送”当动词用。我觉得他们应该在圣诞节把 UnHerd 的会员资格送给朋友或家人。你觉得这是个好主意吗，汤姆？我觉得这是个绝妙的主意。因为有些人，这里说，可能认识某个人，
What does he say? He says, only its Christian understanding makes sense, which I completely agree with. Yeah. How come you didn't like the article? Well, do you know i did i wrote it for unheard last year and i was entitled the myth the myth of pagan christmas
此人需要面对一些不同的视角。好吧，我的意思是，吉尔斯·弗雷泽在读你的文章时不会遇到不同的视角，对吧？反之亦然。但其他人可能会。但一旦你成为 UnHerd 羊群的一部分，
oh my word you're not telling me that giles fraser is stepping on your toes no i didn't i didn't think i don't think of vicar i mean i'm treading on the vicar's toes uh but it's like a slightly different perspective um so my perspective was that uh you know the argument actually that we talked about with ronald hutton in our um episode on paganism the idea that christmas is a kind of a christian reworking of a primal pagan festival i disputed that so that's right you don't agree with that at all do you no that was very much my noise just phrasing clearly so listen i'll tell you what i think people should do i think a lot of people should
人多就有安全感。但如果你不属于那个羊群，如果你认识不属于那个羊群的人，他们可能会以最好的方式，从质疑他们的一些确定性中受益。人多就有安全感。但如果你不属于那个羊群，如果你认识不属于那个羊群的人，他们可能会以最好的方式，从质疑他们的一些确定性中受益。我认为 UnHerd 会员资格可能正适合他们。你不这么认为吗，汤姆？
should it says here gift i don't use the word gift as a verb um i think they should give unheard membership to a friend or family member for christmas do you think that's a good idea tom i think it's a brilliant idea because some people people may know somebody, he says here, who would do with confronting some different perspectives. Well, I mean, Giles Fraser's not going to be encountering different perspectives as he reads your article, is he? Or vice versa. But other people may. But once you become part of the unheard herd,
我同意。而且有一个特惠活动，可以将年度订阅费从 40 英镑降到 39 英镑。这不算什么。他们还会顺便送一个 UnHerd 的袋子，上面写着“免疫羊群心态”。袋子上好像就这么写的，对，确实如此。希望你不会和一大群拿着那个袋子的人一起被拍照，那将是一场灾难，多米尼克。你已经开过这个玩笑了。我知道，但这个笑话太好了，所以我说了
then there's safety in numbers. But if you're not part of that herd, and if you know people who are not part of that herd, they may, in the nicest possible way, benefit from questioning some of their certainties Then there's safety in numbers. But if you're not part of that herd, and if you know people who are not part of that herd, they may, in the nicest possible way, benefit from questioning some of their certainties. And I think unheard membership could be for them. Don't you, Tom?
两遍。好吧，所以……如果你想利用这个优惠——记住，目前降价了10英镑——这是一个极好的优惠。UnHerd 是一个绝佳的网站，里面充满了各种精彩的内容，而且不仅仅是由我和多米尼克写的。你可以访问 unheard.com 了解更多信息：unherd.com。欢迎回到《历史余音》。我们再次进入了悬念区。蕾切尔·莫利要在半小时左右的时间里讲完七座教堂，蕾切尔。开始吧。我们要少说多讲。
I do. And there's a special offer which brings an annual subscription down £10 to only £39. That's nothing. And they'll throw in an unheard bag along with it, immune to herd mentality. It says that on the bag apparently yeah it does let's hope you don't get photographed with a lot of other people with that bag that'd be disastrous dominic you already made that joke i know but it's good so good i made it
开始。好的，太棒了。所以圣诞假期，全都是关于暴饮暴食和看电影的对吧？所以有很多人年复一年都在看的经典邪典电影。《34街的奇迹》（Miracle on 34th Street），
twice okay so um if you want to take up that offer and remember that's uh it's down 10 pounds at the moment um fabulous offer unheard is a wonderful site full of amazing stuff uh and not just by um me and dominic uh you can visit unheard.com to find out more unherd.com welcome back to the rest is history uh we are once again in jeopardy territory rachel morley has seven churches to do in half an hour or so, Rach. So go. We're going to talk less and you're going to talk more.
好的，所以嗯，如果您想接受这个优惠，请记住——目前优惠减免了10英镑——这真的是个棒极了的优惠。Unherd是一个充满精彩内容的绝佳网站，不仅有我和多米尼克的作品，您还可以访问unherd.com了解更多。unherd.com欢迎回到《历史的剩余》，我们再次进入了紧张的时刻，瑞秋·莫利要在半小时左右的时间里参观七座教堂，瑞秋。所以，快去吧。我们要少说，你得多说。
Go. Okay, great. So Christmas break, it's all about a time for overeating and watching films, right? So there are lots of cult classics that people watch year in, year out. Miracle on 34th Street,
去吧。好的，太棒了。所以圣诞假期，这就是一个暴饮暴食和看电影的时期，对吧？所以有很多人年复一年都在看的邪典经典，比如《三十四街的奇迹》，
It's a Wonderful Life, Home Alone, Die Hard. For the Die Hard fans out there, there's a scene in heidi lake church which in real life is a highland lake community church in denver colorado or some people might like chitty chitty bang bang that was a christmas movie in 1968 if you're a chitty chitty bang bang fan you should go to saint james's burton lazars in leicestershire that's a very fine norman church
《生活多美好》、《小鬼当家》、《虎胆龙威》。对于《虎胆龙威》的粉丝来说，海蒂湖教堂里有一个场景，现实中它是科罗拉多州丹佛市的一个高地湖泊社区教堂；或者有些人可能喜欢《飞天万能车》，那是1968年的一部圣诞电影，如果你是《飞天万能车》的粉丝，你应该去莱斯特郡伯顿拉扎尔斯的圣詹姆斯教堂，那是一座非常精美的诺曼式教堂，
that actually once homed one of England's first leper hospitals in the 12th century. But anyway, in the churchyard you'll see the Zabrowski family grave. Count Louis Zabrowski died aged 29. He was a racing car driver and he was the owner of the real life Chitty Chitty Bang Bang that he built himself and that Ian Fleming
它在12世纪时实际上曾是英格兰最早的麻风病院之一。但无论如何，在教堂墓地里你会看到扎布罗夫斯基家族的墓。路易·扎布罗夫斯基伯爵去世时年仅29岁。他是一名赛车手，也是现实生活中由他自己制造的“飞天万能车”的主人，伊恩·弗莱明正是以此为灵感
wrote his novel on. Both of Louis' parents were dead by the time he was 16 and he was at that point reported to be the fourth richest child in the world. Fourth richest. Fourth richest.
写下了他的小说。路易的双亲在他16岁时就都去世了，据当时报道，他那时是世界上第四富有的小孩。第四富有。第四富有。
But I have never seen Die Hard and I've never seen Chitty Chitty Bang Bang and I have no idea what I'm talking about. So I'm just going to stick to what I do. That's never stopped us
但我没看过《虎胆龙威》，也没看过《飞天万能车》，而且我根本不知道自己在说什么。所以我打算只讲我擅长的。这可从来没阻止过我们
on this podcast. Yeah, we've never, that never happened. So M.R.ames that we've spoken about just before the break his ghost stories are very much derived on a victorian tradition and one of the most beloved victorian ghost stories is of course charles dickens the christmas carol yes our previous episode so um since it was written in 1843 and according to wikipedia and my pretty unreliable counting efforts there there have been 25 film versions, 30 cartoon
在这个播客里胡说八道。是的，我们从没……这事从没发生过。所以我们刚才在休息前谈到的M.R.詹姆斯，他的鬼故事很大程度上源自维多利亚时代的传统，而最受喜爱的维多利亚时代鬼故事之一，当然就是查尔斯·狄更斯的《圣诞颂歌》了。没错，在我们上一期节目里……所以，嗯，自从它在1843年问世以来，根据维基百科和我相当不靠谱的统计，已经有25个电影版本、30个动画
versions and 22 TV shows as well as loads of audio and radio versions. So I think it's probably one of the most adaptive things. And a mime version. Marcel Marceau. That sounds terrible though, doesn't it? I mean, that sounds rubbish.
版本和22个电视剧版本，以及大量的音频和广播版本。所以我想它可能是改编次数最多的作品之一。还有一个哑剧版本。马塞尔·马索。听起来挺糟糕的，对吧？我是说，听起来太烂了。
His body is his tool. Thanks for that you're welcome but for one of like the most kind of enduring popular and adapted stories
他的身体就是他的工具。谢谢你，不客气。但作为过去150多年、160年左右以来，最具有持久流行度且被改编最多的故事之一，
kind of you know of the last 150 whatever years 160 years it actually took Dickens just six weeks to write the story
狄更斯实际上只用了六周时间就写完了这个故事，
which is about double the time it takes Dominic to write an adventure in time book ah very good good publicity Good publicity. Good publicity again.
这大约是多米尼克写一本“时间冒险”书所用时间的两倍。啊，非常棒，很好的宣传。很好的宣传。又是一次很好的宣传。
So they're available for more good booksellers, and it's not too late to get your Christmas shopping in. So anyway, it took six weeks for him to write, and he really had such high hopes for it, but it didn't start off too well. Of the first 6,000 copies, he only made a profit of £137, whereas he had hoped to make a profit of about £1,000. And that was because um the printing and binding was really expensive but also there were pirate copies being sold for just 2p
所以它们各大优质书店都有售，现在去买圣诞礼物还来得及。总之，他花了六周时间写完，对它抱有极高的期望，但开局并不是很顺利。在前6000册里，他只赚了137英镑的利润，而他原本希望赚取大约1000英镑的利润。这是因为，嗯，印刷和装订真的很贵，而且还有只要2便士就能买到的盗版书在出售。
um claire tomalin in her excellent charles dickens biography has you know loads of information about all of this and i would absolutely recommend claire tomalin biography on absolutely anything thomas hardy samuel peeps everybody she writes brilliant books. But all of that said, after a slow start, it did take off. And, you know, as I said, it's arguably the best known and most popular Dickens story. In its first hundred years, it sold two million copies in the US alone. Dickens took it on tour in England and he wrote and performed all of these extended sections with different kind of, you know, drawing out different characters and their stories. People queued and thousands were regularly disappointed because they couldn't get in or they couldn't get tickets.
克莱尔·托马琳在她那本极佳的查尔斯·狄更斯传记里，掌握了关于这一切的大量信息，我绝对向大家推荐克莱尔·托马琳关于任何事物的传记，不管是托马斯·哈代、塞缪尔·佩皮斯还是所有人，她写书真是太棒了。但话虽如此，在慢热的开端之后，它确实火了。而且，正如我所说，它可以说是最广为人知、最受欢迎的狄更斯故事。在它问世后的头一百年里，仅在美国就卖出了两百万册。狄更斯带着它在英格兰巡回演出，他编写并表演了所有这些加长片段，生动地刻画了不同的人物及其故事。人们大排长龙，数以千计的人经常因为进不去或买不到票而感到失望。
But Dickens sets his story in London, like he told us all about yesterday. So I'm kind of probably going to be repeating some of the things that you've said. But some of the churches and the churchy locations such as St. Paul's Cathedral are clearly identified and we know where they are and what they are. But for others, I've consulted the website london walking tours and they convincingly argue that the ancient tower of a church with the gruff old bell that was always peeping slyly down on scrooge out of a gothic window in the wall is saint michael's corn hill that's what we said that's what we said that Rachel agrees with us yes okay great did we great. Did we consult the same website?
但狄更斯把他的故事背景设定在伦敦，就像他昨天向我们详细介绍的那样。所以我可能大概会重复一些你们说过的话。不过，像圣保罗大教堂这样的某些教堂和与教堂相关的地点被明确标识了，我们知道它们在哪里、是什么样的。但对于其他地点，我参考了“伦敦徒步游”网站，他们令人信服地论证了那座古老的教堂钟楼，上面挂着粗鲁古老的大钟，总是从墙上的哥特式窗户里狡黠地窥视着斯克鲁奇，那就是康希尔的圣迈克尔教堂。我们就是这么说的！我们就是这么说的！雷切尔也同意我们的看法，对吧？是的，太好了。真的吗？太好了。我们查的是同一个网站吗？
I think we probably did. Probably. If you Google Dickens locations. It's a current location. We would never do that. I mean, I was at the Bodleian Library. Yeah. Fine.
我想我们大概是的。大概吧。如果你在谷歌上搜索狄更斯相关的地点。这是一个现成的地点。我们才不会那样做呢。我是说，我当时在博德利图书馆。好吧。行吧。
So London is all well and good, but I'd like to give the final word and the final church, number four, to my beloved Shrewsbury. They filmed A Christmas Carol in Shrewsbury in the 1980s. 1984, to be precise, Dominic. I answered an advert in that local paper, the British North Journal, to appear as an urchin,
伦敦固然很好，但我想要把最后的总结和第四座教堂留给我挚爱的什鲁斯伯里。他们在20世纪80年代在什鲁斯伯里拍摄了《圣诞颂歌》。准确地说，是1984年，多米尼克。我曾在当地报纸《英国北方日报》上看到一则广告，申请扮演一个街头流浪儿，
but they didn't select me. Dominic, you're acting career. They didn't select me. It's the whole Paddington story all over again, Tom. So you could have played Paddington and you could have played a Victorian urchin. Yeah, I probably would have been like Scrooge or something, but I missed out.
但他们没有选中我。多米尼克，你的演艺生涯啊。他们没有选中我。这简直就是帕丁顿熊的故事重演啊，汤姆。所以你本可以演帕丁顿熊，你本可以演一个维多利亚时代的流浪儿。对，我大概会演像斯克鲁奇之类的人吧，但我错过了。
You're too well-fed to really be a Victorian urchin. Oh, thanks, Rachel. Thanks. Sorry. Sorry. You could be a Victorian philanthropist, though. Yeah. Yeah, I could.
你吃得太饱了，演不了真正的维多利亚时代流浪儿。哦，谢谢你，雷切尔。谢谢。抱歉。抱歉。不过你可以演一个维多利亚时代的慈善家。对。对，我可以。
I could have been Mr. Fezziwig. I'd have been Mr. Fezziwig. Or, you know, Mr. Watermelon, the fella from the Muppet version. Watermelon? Melon? Honeydew. Honeydew. Honeydew. Mr. Fizzy Wig. Or, you know, Mr. Watermelon, the fella from the Muppets version. Watermelon? Melon? Honeydew! Honeydew! Honeydew!
我本可以演费齐威格先生。我会演费齐威格先生。或者，你知道的，西瓜先生，来自布偶电影版里的那个家伙。西瓜？甜瓜？蜜瓜。蜜瓜。蜜瓜。费齐威格先生。或者，你知道的，西瓜先生，来自布偶电影版里的那个家伙。西瓜？甜瓜？蜜瓜！蜜瓜！蜜瓜！
Mr. Watermelon! Sorry, Honeydew! That would make me beaker. It would, it would. That's actually very apt. It is, actually. Oh, God. Anyway.
西瓜先生！抱歉，是蜜瓜！那我会变成烧杯。会的，会的。这其实非常贴切。确实如此。哦，天哪。不管怎样。
Terrifying. Number four. 1984, A Christmas Carol was filmed in Shrewsbury uh there's loads of cgi so they put in like saint paul's and all of the london landmarks to um uh to kind of make it look like london but there's one prop that remains in shrewsbury in a churchyard to this day from that film so it's been there for like nearly 40 years and that is in the churchyard of saint chad's which is um oh it's just it's the new saint chad so this is the old saint chad which is a bit old and ruined and it's a bit sad but it's having repairs at the moment but if you go to the new saint chad
太可怕了。第四个。1984年，《圣诞颂歌》在什鲁斯伯里拍摄。嗯，里面有大量的电脑特效，所以他们加上了圣保罗大教堂和所有的伦敦地标，嗯，为了让它看起来像伦敦。但有一个道具至今仍然留在什鲁斯伯里的一座教堂墓地里，是从那部电影里留存下来的，所以它已经在那里将近40年了，那就在圣查德教堂的墓地里，那是，嗯，哦，这就是新圣查德教堂，所以这是老圣查德教堂，它有点老旧破损，而且有点凄凉，目前正在进行修缮。但如果你去新圣查德教堂，
it's round it's got a lovely dome and it's you know a lovely georgian church um but if you scrawl scrabble around in the undergrowth there you'll see a huge slab of limestone inscribed with the words ebenezer scrooge and it's still there oh that's good yeah and they never removed it so yeah it's still there so yeah floriac salopia no that's it that's that's a brilliant number four okay great christmas baking i love i love baking i love christmas baking uh i love baking full stop dominic uh has a a something that he describes my baking as
它是圆的，有一个可爱的穹顶，你知道的，这是一座可爱的乔治亚风格教堂。但是如果你在那里的灌木丛中搜寻一番，你会看到一块巨大的石灰石板，上面刻着“埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇”几个字，它居然还在那儿！哦，太棒了！对啊，他们从来没把它移走，所以它真的还在那儿！所以，萨洛比亚之花！不，就是这样，这是一个绝妙的第四个。好的，太棒了。圣诞烘焙。我喜欢，我喜欢烘焙，我喜欢圣诞烘焙。嗯，我喜欢纯粹的烘焙，多米尼克，他有一种形容我烘焙的方式——
never knowingly underbaked there is some truth but Rachel makes very very good cakes Tom she wants she's made a lot of birthday cakes that have occasioned comment from other parents
从不故意烤不熟。这确实有几分真，但雷切尔做的蛋糕真的非常好，汤姆。她做过很多生日蛋糕，引发了其他家长的热议，
who said who's your professional cake maker by the Death Star Rachel made a whole Death Star spherical because it's just been Arthur's birthday Arthur's birthday the Hogwarts Hogwarts your professional cake maker. Like the Death Star. Rachel made a whole Death Star spherical out of chocolate cake. Arthur's birthday. Arthur's birthday.
他们说：“谁是你们的专业蛋糕师？”就像死星一样！雷切尔用巧克力蛋糕做了一个完整的球形死星。阿瑟的生日。阿瑟的生日。霍格沃茨。霍格沃茨。你们的专业蛋糕师。就像死星一样。雷切尔用巧克力蛋糕做了一个完整的球形死星。阿瑟的生日。阿瑟的生日。
The Hogwarts. Hogwarts. Anyway, that's all fine. So one thing that I use in all of my baking, not all of it, but most of it, would be self-raising flour.
霍格沃茨。霍格沃茨。不管怎样，这些都没问题。所以我在所有烘焙中都会用到的一样东西——也不是所有，但大部分——就是自发粉。
So does anybody know about the history of self-raising flour? Tom, you must know all about this. You call yourself historians. Anyway, so, okay.
那么有人知道自发粉的历史吗？汤姆，你一定对这个了如指掌。你自称是历史学家呢。总之，好吧。
The next time you open your kitchen cupboard, spare a thought for Henry Jones. Henry Jones was born in 1812 in Monmouthshire and he went on to Bristol to make his fortune. And he kind of crossed over the Severn Estuary into the metropolis of the West. And he set up a business in Broadmead in Bristol. And he was basically a baker. And he was very innovative. And in 1845, when he was 33 years old, he invented something that made his fortune and kind of changed the baking world forever. Forever.
下次你打开厨房橱柜时，请顺便想想亨利·琼斯。亨利·琼斯于1812年出生在蒙茅斯郡，后来他前往布里斯托尔去闯世界。他穿过了塞文河口，来到了西方的大都会。他在布里斯托尔的布罗德米德开创了自己的事业。他基本上是个面包师。而且他非常有创新精神。1845年，当他33岁时，他发明了一样东西，这让他发了财，并且某种程度上永远改变了烘焙世界。永远。
He basically invented self-raising flour. Okay, that's good. It is really good. And he obtained a patent for it. And Henry Jones Bristol was all great, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. He was appointed purveyor of the patent flour and biscuits to Queen Victoria. And basically, what was very interesting, I think, is that the armed forces of the crown were really slow to take up. They could have used his flower for all of their things, but they were really slow to take up.
他基本上发明了自发粉。好吧，这很棒。这真的很棒。而且他为此获得了专利。亨利·琼斯在布里斯托尔的一切都很顺利，啦啦啦啦啦。他被任命为维多利亚女王的专利面粉和饼干御用供应商。基本上，非常有趣的是，我认为王室军队对它的接受速度非常慢。他们本可以在所有事情上都使用他的面粉，但他们接受得实在太慢了。
They were very distrustful of it. And it wasn't until... Was that the fault of Dominic, the useless commander? Duke of Cambridge. The Duke of Cambridge, who was the most incompetent person that we saw in our... In our statues. Yeah, our statues walk. And you were really keen that he continue to stand as a symbol of incompetence
他们对它非常不信任。直到……那是无能指挥官多米尼克的错吗？剑桥公爵。剑桥公爵，那是我们在我们的……在我们的雕像中看到的最无能的人。对，我们的雕像在游行。而你真的很热衷于让他继续作为无能的象征，
yes sort of inspiration to people yes and so he missed out on self-raising flour self-raising flour but hold on why would the what military purpose
是的，某种对人们的“启发”，对吧。所以他错过了自发粉，错过了自发粉。但是等等，军事上怎么会需要……
to self no no no like for the food for food like for biscuits they could throw it in the faces of the French
自发粉？不，不，不，是为了食物，为了食物，就像饼干一样。他们可以把它扔到法国人的脸上。
no biscuits and weevils I'm joking go on Rich yeah fine so you know the kind of biscuits and the kind of the staple of the Royal Navy, they could have had nice biscuits, basically, but they didn't.
不，饼干和象鼻虫。我开玩笑的，继续吧，瑞奇。好吧，所以你知道那种饼干，皇家海军的主食，他们本可以吃到好吃的饼干的，基本上，但他们没有。
Until Florence Nightingale herself intervened during the Crimean War. And basically she got self-raising flour used by the army for their biscuits. So she's got one over Mary Seacole at last on flour. Yeah, she has. But anyway, basically, this is a quick one. Henry Jones, self-raising flower. He was born in Monmouthshire in Wales. He got married in a church, which is a friend of a friend of churches church.
直到弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔在克里米亚战争期间亲自介入。基本上她让军队开始使用自发粉来制作饼干。所以她总算在面粉这件事上压了玛丽·西科尔一头。是的，她确实压了一头。不过不管怎样，简单来说，这是一个简短的故事：亨利·琼斯，自发粉。他出生在威尔士的蒙茅斯郡。他在一座教堂里结了婚，那座教堂可以说是“教堂之友的教堂”。
It's St. Michael's and All Angels, Llanfahangl Rogget. Say that again. Dominic. It's Llanfahangl Rogget. Very good. No, I just wanted to hear it. I thought it was really nice. Right.
那是兰汉格尔罗盖特的圣迈克尔和诸天使教堂。再念一遍，多米尼克。是兰汉格尔罗盖特。非常好。不，我只是想听听。我觉得这名字真好听。对。
Actually, it is absolutely beautiful. Llanfahangl Rogget actually translates as the Church of St. Michael in the Valley of the Road Year. And it's so beautiful. That's a beautiful name. It is lovely. It is a beautiful name. Very nice.
其实，它真的非常漂亮。“兰汉格尔罗盖特”翻译过来其实就是“路年山谷中的圣迈克尔教堂”。这名字太美了。这名字真好听。确实很美。这是一个美丽的名字。非常好。
Anyway, that's Henry Jones. He got married in that church at Llanfahangl Rogget. And he's buried in St. Mary's Caldecott churchyard not nearby but his invention lives on and is used every single day by bakers all across the world okay so that's four is that five no that's five that's five so we're halfway there we're halfway through yeah we're nearly there great um way up north where the air gets cold there's a tale about Christmas that we've all been told. That's the Beach Boys.
总之，这就是亨利·琼斯。他在兰汉格尔罗盖特的座教堂里结了婚。他被安葬在卡尔迪科特的圣玛丽教堂墓地里，离那儿不远，但他的发明长存世间，被全世界千千万万的面包师每天都在使用。好了，那是第四个，那是第五个吗？不，那是第五个，那是第五个。所以我们进行到一半了，我们走了一半了，对，我们快到了。太棒了，嗯……远在北方，空气变冷的地方，有一个关于圣诞节的故事，我们所有人都听过。那是海滩男孩的歌。
And they're singing about little Saint Nick. So Saint Nicholas was a 4th century Turkish bishop. And he became the patron saint of children after he gave three bags of gold as a dowry to save three sisters from prostitution. And he revived three murdered boys that had been pickled in brine. And he had loads of other miracles including the miracle of the cop i don't really know if we have time to be talking about the miracle of the cop but anyway um can you can you describe it in a sentence a long sentence that has no i'm amazed to hear that okay a rich man prays at saint nick's tomb and says if he gives him a son he'll donate a golden cup to the tomb.
他们唱的是小圣尼克。所以圣尼古拉斯是一位4世纪的土耳其主教。他成了儿童的主保圣人，因为他曾送出三袋黄金作为嫁妆，拯救了三个免于沦落风尘的姐妹；他还复活了三个被腌制在盐水里的被谋杀的男孩。他还有过许多其他神迹，包括金杯的神迹。我真的不知道我们现在有没有时间讨论金杯的神迹，不过，嗯……你能用一句话描述它吗？一个很长的句子，没有……听到这个我惊呆了。好吧。一个富人在圣尼克的墓前祈祷，并说如果圣尼克赐予他一个儿子，他就会向墓地捐献一个金杯。
I don't really know why the dead saint wants a cup, but anyway. The rich man gets the son and he thinks he can be clever and give a fake gold cup to St. Nicholas's tomb. And keep the real gold one for himself. The rich man sends his son to the river with the cup to get some water. The son falls in, disappears and or drowns, we don't know. The rich man is distraught. Then he goes to the tomb with his fake to get some water. The son falls in, disappears and or drowns, we don't know. The rich man is distraught. Then he goes to the tomb with his fake cup and prays and is all weepy. And then a hand appears out of nowhere. It throws the fake cup back at the man and knocks him over.
我其实不太明白为什么一个死去的圣人会想要一个杯子，但不管怎样。富人得到了儿子，他觉得自己可以耍小聪明，送一个假金杯到圣尼古拉斯的墓前，而把真正的金杯留给自己。富人派他的儿子拿着杯子去河边取水。儿子掉进水里，失踪了，或者溺水了，我们不知道。富人悲痛欲绝。然后他带着假杯子来到墓前祈祷，哭得梨花带雨。接着，一只手凭空出现。它把假杯子朝那个人扔了回去，把他撞倒在地。
And then the dead or lost son appears and says, St. Nicholas saved him and hand over the gold cup to the tomb. And you'll get your son back. They do. And everybody lives happily ever after. him and hand over the gold cup to the tomb and you'll get yourself back they do and everybody lives happily ever after anyway um the uh the cycles of saint nicholas's miracles are found in medieval wall paintings in loads of churches like saint mary alder maston and barkshire haddon hall chapel in derbyshire all saints in worth in essex and but i think my favourite depiction has to go to St Nicholas' miracles carved onto the 12th century font at Winchester Cathedral.
然后，那个死去或失踪的儿子出现了，说圣尼古拉斯救了他，并要把金杯交出来献给墓地。这样你就能找回你的儿子。他们照做了。于是大家从此过上了幸福快乐的生活。交出来献给墓地，这样你就能找回你的儿子。他们照做了。于是大家从此过上了幸福快乐的生活。不管怎样，嗯……圣尼古拉斯神迹的循环图画可以在许多教堂的中世纪壁画中找到，比如伯克郡的奥尔德玛斯顿圣玛丽教堂、德比郡的哈登霍尔小教堂、埃塞克斯郡沃思的诸圣教堂，但我认为我最喜欢的描绘，当属刻在温彻斯特大教堂12世纪洗礼盆上的圣尼古拉斯神迹。
And it's a tournay marble font, so Belgian, not real marble, polished black limestone. But on that you have the miracles of reviving the drowned boys, the miracle of the golden cup the miracle of the the girl the prostitution gold dowry things and it's beautifully polished and it's just divine
这是一个图尔奈大理石洗礼盆，所以是比利时的，不是真正的天然大理石，而是抛光的黑色石灰石。但在上面你可以看到复活溺水男孩的神迹、金杯的神迹、女孩沦落风尘的金嫁妆的神迹，它被打磨得光彩照人，简直神圣极了。
and there are only seven tournay marble fonts in the whole of England and four of them are in Hampshire and this one at Winchester Cathedral is just beautifully carved
全英格兰只有七个图尔奈大理石洗礼盆，其中四个在汉普郡，而温彻斯特大教堂这一个雕刻得简直精美绝伦，
you know so distinct 10 out of 10. I'm amazed they don't make more of it, bearing in mind the popularity of Father Christmas. Yeah. Well, talking about Father Christmas, I was actually, once I was reading about this,
你知道的，细节如此清晰，10分满分。考虑到圣诞老人的受欢迎程度，我很惊讶他们居然没有多加利用这一点。对。说到圣诞老人，我其实……当我在阅读相关资料时，
I kind of went down a bit of a rabbit hole and wondered why Santa Claus was called Santa Claus. Do you know this? It's American, isn't it? It's because of, it's melding of traditions in America. Yeah, St. Niklaus. Oh, okay, fine. Isn't that...
我陷入了一个小小的知识迷宫，纳闷为什么圣诞老人（Santa Claus）会被叫作Santa Claus。你知道这个吗？这是美式叫法，对吧？这是因为……这是美国各种传统的融合。对，圣尼古拉斯（St. Niklaus）。哦，原来是这样。
Is that what it is, Rach? Yeah, it's 18th century Dutch families that went to America. So St. Nicholas in Dutch is Sint Niklas. That was shortened to Sinterklaas. And then that eventually became Santa Claus. I'm very fanatical against Santa Claus. I'm very much a Father Christmas fan. You're a Father Christmas fan, aren't you?
是这样的吗，雷切尔？对，这是18th世纪去到美国的荷兰家庭带来的。所以圣尼古拉斯在荷兰语中是Sint Niklas。这个名字被简称为Sinterklaas。然后这个词最终演变成了Santa Claus。我对圣诞老人（Santa Claus）非常反感。我绝对是圣诞老人（Father Christmas）的忠实粉丝。你是Father Christmas的粉丝，对吧？
Are you really? Yeah, we talked about this last year in our previous Christmas special. You never hear the word Santa Claus past my lips, Rach. You would never. And actually, if anybody else says Santa Claus, you always kind of admonish them, don't you? I'm a nice person
真的吗？对，我们去年在我们的上一个圣诞特辑里讨论过这个。雷切尔，你绝不会听到我嘴里蹦出Santa Claus这个词。你绝对听不到。而且事实上，如果其他人说Santa Claus，你总是会纠正他们，对吧？我就是这样一个
that way. A hurling of the lip. Yeah, exactly. The sneer of cold command. No, Tom, it's not even like that. He'll say, Santa Claus? Who's Santa Claus? Who are you talking about? Do you mean Father Christmas? That's what he would say. He'll take back the sixpence that he'd just given to her.
可爱的人。嘴角一撇。对，没错。带着冷酷傲慢的冷笑。不，汤姆，根本不是那样的。他会说：“Santa Claus？谁是Santa Claus？你在说谁？你是说Father Christmas吗？”他会这么说。他甚至会收回刚给她的六便士。
The shoeless chimney sweep. This is a terrible insight into Christmas in this episode. It is. It absolutely is. But it's so good that Rachel comes every year. So, draw your own conclusions. I would say that Dominic is one of the best people to spend Christmas with, I would say. Oh, that is so touching to hear.
那个没有鞋穿的烟囱清扫工。这一期节目简直是对圣诞节的一个可怕剖析。确实是。绝对是。但雷切尔每年都来，这真是太好了。所以，大家自己得出结论吧。我要说的是，多米尼克是陪人过圣诞节的最佳人选之一。哦，听到这个真让人感动。
You're so much fun. So much fun. The jollity of Christmas. I'll be coming for the next ten years. Playing Sir Roger the Covelly. Yeah, exactly. Okay, let's go on. That was number six. Winchester Cathedral. Tourenoy Marble Fond.lly. Yeah, exactly. Okay, let's go on.
你太有趣了。太有趣了。圣诞节的欢乐。我未来十年都会来。扮演科夫利爵士罗杰。对，没错。好了，我们继续。那是第六个。温彻斯特大教堂。图尔奈大理石洗礼盆。里。对，没错。好吧，我们继续。
That was number six, Winchester Cathedral, Tornow Marble Fond, St. Nicholas. Great. Okay, next up is number seven. So there's loads of talk this year, again, like last year, about Christmas being cancelled, second year in a row.
那是第六个，温彻斯特大教堂，图尔奈大理石洗礼盆，圣尼古拉斯。太好了。好的，接下来是第七个。今年大家又在热议圣诞节被取消了，就像去年一样，这是连续第二年了。
Everyone's very sad about it. But actually in Scotland, Christmas was cancelled for about 400 years. Now, Tom, do you know this? You know it, do you, Tom? Yeah. Yeah. I think it only became a holiday in the 60s.
每个人都为此感到很难过。但实际上在苏格兰，圣诞节被取消了大约400年。现在，汤姆，你知道这个吗？你知道的，对吧，汤姆？对。对。我想它直到20世纪60年代才成为一个假日。
Yeah. Dominic didn't know this at all. I tried it out on him last week. Yeah. I didn't know it. I didn't know it. I don't know. I still don't.
是的。多米尼克完全不知道这事。我上周还拿这事试探过他呢。对。我不知道。我真的不知道。我不知道。我到现在还是不知道。
Tell me, Rach. Okay. I will tell you, Dominic. So in 1583, there was a decree made at St. Mungo's Cathedral, which is Glasgow Cathedral. That is number seven. Just so you know, just so there's no doubt. So the Glasgow Kirk rejected a calendar defined by mysterious and superstitious times.
告诉我吧，雷切尔。好吧。我会告诉你的，多米尼克。所以在1583年，圣芒戈大教堂（也就是格拉斯哥大教堂）颁布了一项法令。这就是第七个。让你们知道一下，免得有任何疑问。所以格拉斯哥长老会拒绝了一个由神秘和迷信时间所定义的日历。
Potpourri. No potpourri. Exactly. And they ordered the excommunication of those who celebrated Christmas or Yule. And even singing a Christmas carol was considered a serious crime. Eventually in 1640 an Act of Parliament in Scotland made the celebration of Christmas illegal and even just baking a Christmas bread was a criminal act. Wow that's harsh. It is harsh. The ban was officially repealed in 1712 but the church continued to frown upon any
天主教异端。没有天主教异端。没错。他们下令将那些庆祝圣诞节或尤尔节（冬至节）的人开除教籍。甚至连唱一首圣诞颂歌都被视为严重的罪行。最终在1640年，苏格兰议会通过了一项法案，宣布庆祝圣诞节为非法行为，甚至连烤一块圣诞面包都是犯罪行为。哇，太严厉了。确实严厉。这个禁令在1712年被正式废除，但教会仍然对任何
festive celebrations and the punishment were harsh and there was no public holiday for Christmas people on Christmas day so it wasn't until 1958 so the 25th of December yeah 1958 25th of December became a public holiday in Scotland Boxing Day which we've already talked about in church number two only became a public holiday in 1974 so because Christmas was cancelled, the Scots made a much bigger deal of New Year's Eve or hog money. That's why they make such a big deal of it. I didn't know that.
节日庆祝活动皱眉头，惩罚也很严厉，而且人们在圣诞节当天也没有法定假日，所以直到1958年——也就是12月25日，对，1958年12月25日——圣诞节才在苏格兰成为法定假日。节礼日，我们已经在第二座教堂里谈过了，直到1974年才成为法定假日。所以因为圣诞节被取消了，苏格兰人把除夕（Hogmanay）看得格外重要。这就是为什么他们对除夕如此大肆庆祝。我以前不知道这一点。
That is interesting. So what were they doing in sort of the early 1950s while people in England and indeed the rest of the world were celebrating Christmas? Are people genuinely going to work in Scotland? Really? I think so, yeah. Scottish listeners.
这真有趣。那么在20世纪50年代初，当英格兰人乃至世界其他地方都在庆祝圣诞节时，苏格兰人在做什么？苏格兰人当时真的去上班吗？真的吗？我想是的，对吧。苏格兰的听众们，
Tell us. Tell us, yeah, tell us. What were you doing in 1950s Christmas, 1957? Yeah, exactly. We want to know. But Scotland wasn't the only place that had a cancelled Christmas. So in 17th century England, it was thought that Christmas again was far too much fun.
告诉我们。告诉我们吧，对，告诉我们。1950年代的圣诞节，1957年，你们都在干什么？对，没错。我们想知道。但苏格兰并不是唯一一个经历过取消圣诞节的地方。所以在17th世纪的英格兰，人们认为圣诞节同样玩得太疯了。
It wasn't treated with the solemnity that it deserved. So in 1647, the long parliament said that Christmas should no longer be recognised. And that led to general unrest. And in Canterbury, there was a woman thrown in prison for baking a Christmas pudding. And shopkeepers were imprisoned for not opening their shops on Christmas Day. Yeah. And Father Christmas was banned, wasn't he? There was a cartoon of Father Christmas being sent packing. Wrongly attributed
它没有受到应有的庄严对待。所以在1647年，长期议会宣布不再承认圣诞节。这导致了普遍的动荡。在坎特伯雷，曾有一个女人因为烤圣诞布丁而被投进监狱。店主们因为在圣诞节没有开店营业而被关进监狱。对。而且圣诞老人被禁了，对吧？当时有一幅漫画，画的是圣诞老人被轰走了。人们错误地把这一切
all this to Oliver Cromwell. But he, of course, was not running the country at that point. Your big hero. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
归咎于奥利弗·克伦威尔。但他在那个时候当然并没有在统治国家。你的大英雄。对。对。对。
Everyone knows that. Okay. No, okay. I'm making very good time. I'm very pleased. So St. Mungo's was the church? Number seven, yeah.
人尽皆知。好吧。不，好吧。我们时间非常充裕。我很高兴。所以圣芒戈大教堂就是那座教堂？第七个，对。
Yeah. Because people were complaining the last time that I didn't have an active Scottish church in my list. you've got a cathedral an active scottish cathedral now so yeah happy happy christmas um okay so the next one uh at this time of the year lots of people will be getting new kind of diaries or calendars and their christmas stockings on christmas morning or if you don't get one in
因为上次有人抱怨我的名单里没有一座活跃的苏格兰教堂。你现在有一座大教堂了，一座活跃的苏格兰大教堂，所以，圣诞快乐！嗯……好了，接下来一个，在这个时节，很多人都会在圣诞早晨的圣诞袜里拿到新的日记本或日历，或者如果你在袜子里没有收到，
your stocking, you might get a free one from your local Chinese, if you're lucky. But there's a church in Kent that has the coolest and the most difficult to read calendar etched into one of its walls. So this church, church number eight, is St. Mary's East Street, and this is calendars. So this is really hard for me to try to explain. I'm going to do my absolute best. But there's one pillar, and it was carved in the 1320s, and it's got this Domenical dial carved into it. Tom, you might know about it.
运气好的话，你可能会从中餐馆那里免费得到一本。但在肯特郡有一座教堂，它的其中一面墙上刻着最酷、也最难以解读的日历。所以这座教堂，第八座教堂，是圣玛丽东街教堂，这里有日历。所以这对我来说真的很难解释。我会尽我最大的努力。但有一根柱子，是1320年代雕刻的，上面雕刻了这个“主日日盘”。汤姆，你可能听说过。
Dominic, you won't know anything. I don't. So I think it's unique in English churches. If it's not unique, it's unique in English churches. If it's not unique, it's absolutely very, very rare. So it's called a Domenical Dial or a Sunday Letter Dial. And what it involves is it's four concentric circles, and they're divided into 28 equal parts. And that depicts the 28 years of the solar cycle. And the 28 parts carry really deeply cut Lombardic letters, A to G,
多米尼克，你什么都不知道。我确实不知道。所以我想它在英格兰教堂中是独一无二的。如果不是独一无二的，那它在英格兰教堂中也绝对是非常、非常罕见的。它被称为“主日日盘”或“主日字母盘”。它包含的内容是四个同心圆，被均分为28个相等的部分。这描绘了太阳周期的28年。这28个部分带有深深镌刻的伦巴底体字母A到G，
and they each appear 28, sorry, each letter appears four times in the 28 segments. And then in the next outer ring, each letter appears once, and the double lettering is allowed to allow for leap years. You know who'd like this it's seb falck who did medieval science yeah he'd love a medieval calendar well the thing is i'm going to try to explain how it works but i don't really know so i'm going to you know right well should we just say it works should we just say it kind of works no tom i have things okay okay okay sorry no um so what the dial was used for specifically it was it was used to calculate the day of Easter in the following year.
它们每个出现28次——抱歉，每个字母在28个区段中出现四次。然后在下一个外圈中，每个字母出现一次，设置双字母是为了适应闰年。你知道谁会喜欢这个吗？就是研究中世纪科学的塞布·福克，对，他一定会喜欢中世纪日历。好吧，问题是，我打算试着解释它是怎么运作的，但我其实也不知道，所以我要（笑）……好吧，我们是不是应该直接说它能用？我们是不是应该直接说它大概能用？不，汤姆，我还有东西……好吧，好吧，抱歉，不……那么，这个日盘具体是用来做什么的呢？它是用来计算第二年复活节的日期的。
And from that, then you could calculate the dates of the subsequent festivals and feast days, including Christmas. So I really haven't been able to get my head around how it works. But the letters need to be read in conjunction with the golden numbers. And each letter corresponds to a different number. So A equals zero, G equals one, F equals two. That's a very strange way of ordering it. I know, exactly. This is like the worst Christmas game ever.
从那以后，你就可以计算随后的节日和斋期的日期，包括圣诞节。所以我真的没法搞懂它是怎么运作的。但这些字母需要结合“金数”来阅读。每个字母对应一个不同的数字。所以A等于0，G等于1，F等于2。这是一种非常奇怪的排序方式。我知道，没错。这就像是有史以来最糟糕的圣诞游戏。
And if you roll a six. So the Sunday letters are set out in the Book of Common Prayer, tables and rules for movable and immovable feasts. And apparently it will all be good and the calculations will be good and true until 2099 so that's pretty good going right yeah so okay this is apparently this is how it works you take whatever year it is like 2021 you add to that a quarter of that year. Then you add the number six. Right. You stand on one leg.
如果你掷出一个六……所以主日字母被列在《公祷书》中，关于可移动和不可移动节日的表格和规则里。显然这一切运转良好，而且这些计算将一直准确有效到2099年，所以这相当厉害了，对吧？是的，所以……好吧，据说它是这样运作的：你取任意一个年份，比如2021年，加上这个年份的四分之一。然后加上数字6。对。单腿站立。
Then you divide all of that by seven. And whatever the remainder is, i.e. zero to six, that will correspond to a letter on the wall. That is so brilliant. And do they do it? There must be a simpler way than that. No. But, yeah. So it way than that. But yeah. So it still works?
然后把所有这些除以7。无论余数是多少，也就是0到6，它将对应墙上的一个字母。这太绝了。他们真的是这么做的吗？一定有比这更简单的方法吧。没有。但是，对。所以……还有比这更简单的方法吗？但对。所以它还能用？
Apparently, yeah. Apparently it still works. What fun. Where's this again? Where's this church? St. Mary's East Street in Kent. So it's a really cool church and this is a brilliant device.
显然是的。显然它仍然能用。太有趣了。这是哪里来着？这是哪座教堂？肯特郡的圣玛丽东街教堂。所以这是一座非常酷的教堂，这是一个绝妙的装置。
I have no idea how it works. Tom, you should go. It's not that far from you. I'm going to go. I'm going to go, yeah. Yeah, you should go and try and figure out how it works. Those long winter should go. It's not that far from you. I'm going to go. Yeah, you should go and try and figure out how it works. Those long winter days will just fly by. There's like...
我完全不知道它是怎么运作的。汤姆，你应该去看看。离你不是很远。我要去。我要去，对。对，你应该去看看，并试着弄清楚它是怎么运作的。漫长的冬日时光就会飞逝而去了。这里有……
There's a thing that the Kent Archaeological Society have done where they've tried to explain how it works. I haven't figured... I read it carefully. Well, there's the challenge for 2022. We'll try and work that out. Yeah. So is that number seven?
肯特考古学会做过一件事，他们试着解释它是怎么运作的。我还没弄懂……我仔细读过了。好吧，这就是2022年的挑战。我们会试着把它弄明白。所以那是第七个吗？
That's number eight. Great, so we've got two more to go. We've got two more in six minutes. Fine. Perfect, so you can take your time. I can, yeah. Okay, so picture the scene. It's New Year's Eve and you're in Camelot.
那是第八个。太好了，我们还有两个。我们在六分钟内还要讲两个。很好。完美，所以你可以慢慢来。我可以，对。好吧，想象一下这个场景。那是除夕夜，你身处卡米洛特。
King Arthur and his pals are celebrating the Christmas season and in comes the mysterious Green Knight who joins the fun and the games. And he challenges any knight to strike him with an axe. And if in return, he can take a return blow a year and one day. Did you do an episode on Sir Gawain and the Green Knight? No, we haven't done that.
亚瑟王和他的伙伴们正在庆祝圣诞节，这时神秘的绿骑士走了进来，加入了欢乐和游戏中。他向任何骑士发起挑战，要求对方用斧头砍他。作为回报，他可以在一年零一天后回击一拳。你们做过关于《高文爵士与绿骑士》的一期节目吗？不，我们还没做过。
Yeah, we're mulling it. Well, maybe you should. I just saw the film about it last week. Oh, okay. Very good. So this is the story of Gawain and the green knight so this knight called um sir gawain he accepts the green um the green knight's uh challenge and he strikes his axe and he actually beheads the knight but the green knight just stands up
对，我们在琢磨。那也许你们应该做一期。我上周刚看过关于它的电影。哦，很好。所以这就是高文与绿骑士的故事，这个叫……嗯，高文爵士的骑士接受了绿……绿骑士的挑战，他挥起斧头，真的把骑士的头砍了下来，但绿骑士直接站起身，
picks up his head sticks it back on he's absolutely fine and he reminds gawain of the appointed time and place that he is going to have his you know his reciprocal blow so it will be one year and one day time so it'll be new year's day the following year and it will be in a place called the green chapel right so for centuries scholars have tried to figure out where that green chapel is it's described as only an earthen mound containing a cavern but most accursed so there are two places in the northwest midlands the scholars think the location of the green chapel could be so the first one which is church number nine it's not really a church but sort of
捡起自己的头，把它安回去，他完全没事，并且他提醒高文在指定的时间和地点接受他的回击，也就是一年零一天之后。所以那将是第二年的元旦，地点在一个叫“绿色教堂”的地方。几个世纪以来，学者们一直试图弄清楚那个绿色教堂在哪里。对它的描述仅仅是一个包含洞穴的土丘，但极其受诅咒。所以西北米德兰兹有两处地方，学者们认为可能是绿色教堂的所在地。
the church sort of the church uh is lud's church do No. Okay. So Ludd's Church is a deep chasm in the Gradback Hillside in Staffordshire. It's created by this massive landslip and it's this close, damp, overgreen, bright green mossy kind of chasm in the rock. It's a really good place for a green chapel because it's green. But it's also a place where
所以第一处，也就是第九座教堂——其实不是一座教堂，而算是……算是那种“教堂”，嗯……就是勒德教堂。不。好吧。所以勒德教堂是斯塔福德郡格拉德巴赫山坡上的一个深长裂谷。它是由这处巨大的山体滑坡形成的，这是一个狭窄、潮湿、长满亮绿色苔藓的岩石裂谷。这里确实是个很好的“绿色教堂”候选地，因为它到处都是绿色的。但它也是一个地方，
the Lollards, these proto-Protestant followers of John Wycliffe met to worship in the 15th century and it's thought that Ludd's church might be named after Walter de Luddank who was captured there at one of their meetings and to me that kind of dark space
约翰·威克里夫的早期新教信徒罗拉德派曾在15世纪在这里聚会做礼拜，人们认为勒德教堂可能是以沃尔特·德·勒丁克的名字命名的，他在他们的一次聚会上在那里被捕。对我来说，那种黑暗的空间
kind of evokes the fear and the evil and the cursed you know, the cursedness that you'd expect going into a chapel. Rachel, it's not a chapel now. No, no, no. It's just a cave. It's just a cave, but it's called Ludd's Church. You could go and pray in it if you wanted, Tom. I mean, no one's going to stop you. Or sharpen my axe, isn't it?
某种程度上唤起了那种恐惧、邪恶以及你进入一座教堂时所期望感受到的诅咒感。雷切尔，它现在可不是一座教堂。不，不，不。它只是一个洞穴。它只是一个洞穴，但它被称为“勒德教堂”。汤姆，如果你想的话，你可以去里面祈祷。我是说，没人会阻止你。或者去磨我的斧头，对吧？
There's kind of whetstone in the poem. Tom, are you being very pedantic, Tom, saying it's not a church? Because I have experts on my list. No, Rachel, no, no. I'm absolutely not. I just wondered whether it was, you know, a kind of groovy green chapel. Groovy green chapel. Go for midnight mass or something.
诗里好像提到过磨刀石。汤姆，你是不是太迂腐了，汤姆，非说它不是一座教堂？因为我的名单里可是有专家的。不，雷切尔，不，不。我绝对没有。我只是在想这到底是不是一个……那种时髦的绿色教堂。时髦的绿色教堂。去那儿做子夜弥撒什么的。
Yeah, Sir Gawain and the groovy green chapel. I just think they're missing a trick there, the Church of England or whoever. Rachel has strong views about the Church of England, Tom, we don't want to get into that. Well, somebody could take it, some church could take it over and make it into a chapel because Green Night, it's been in this film this year, I'm sure people
对，高文爵士与时髦绿色教堂。我只是觉得英国国教或者随便什么机构在那里错失了一个好机会。雷切尔对英国国教有强烈的看法，汤姆，我们不想卷入那个话题。好吧，也许有人可以接手，某个教堂可以把它接管过来，把它改造成一座教堂，因为绿骑士今年在电影里出现过，我确信人们
would love to go there. So if you want to take Tom Holland up on his promotional offer, get in touch with him and Tom Holland's Green Chapel could be open. There's terrible winter wonderlands that people go to just before Christmas Day. They complain. The queues were massive.
会很乐意去那儿参观。所以如果你想接受汤姆·霍兰德的促销提议，去联系他吧，“汤姆·霍兰德的绿色教堂”随时可以开张。人们在圣诞节前夕去的那种可怕的冬季仙境。他们抱怨。排队的队伍长得要命。
Yet another Tom Holland's Green Chapel failure. The Green Knight, you know, he wasn't a giant. Yeah, all that kind of stuff. Yeah, no, it's very exciting. Okay. Anyway, that's Ludd's church, right? And that's your church? That's number nine.
又一个“汤姆·霍兰德的绿色教堂”烂尾项目。绿骑士，你知道的，他可不是个巨人。对，所有那种乱七八糟的东西。对，不，这非常令人兴奋。好吧。不管怎样，那是勒德教堂，对吧？那是你的教堂？那是第九个。
But I just want to stick in there that, so other people suggest that the location for the Green Chapel could be Nantor Cave at Wetton Mill, which is only about 10 miles away. So this is definitely a mound with a cave. It's got multiple entrances into it. But parts of it has kind of collapsed, like the roof has collapsed. It's very cave. It's got multiple entrances into it. But parts of it has kind of collapsed. Like the roof has collapsed.
但我只想插一句，其他人认为绿色教堂的所在地可能是韦顿米尔的南托尔洞穴，那里离这儿只有大约10英镑——哦不，10英里远。所以这绝对是一个带洞穴的土丘。它有多个入口。但它的部分结构已经坍塌了，比如屋顶坍塌了。里面非常像个洞穴。它有多个入口。但它的部分结构已经坍塌了，比如屋顶坍塌了。
It's very overgrown inside. So it's kind of hard to kind of see what it would have looked like in the 14th century. Quick question for both of you, because you will both know more about this than me. Why do people think it has to be in Staffordshire? Is it because of the dialect of the poem? Right. Okay. Thank you.
里面杂草丛生。所以很难看出它在14世纪时会是什么样子。问你们两个一个快问快答，因为你们俩对这个都比我了解得多。为什么人们认为它一定在斯塔福德郡？是因为这首诗的方言吗？对。好吧。谢谢。
I mean, of course, it's not real, is it? I mean, there wasn't really a Green Knight. It could be either or none of them. You don't know. Yeah, you don't know. Rachel's just done an impersonation that won't mean anything to anybody but me. Because we've already covered talking snakes in this year's podcast with Guiding Alexander the Great Across the Desert.
我的意思是，当然，这不是真的，对吧？我是说，现实中并没有什么绿骑士。它可能是其中任何一个，也可能都不是。你不知道。对，你不知道。雷切尔刚刚模仿了一个只有我才懂的梗。因为我们在今年的播客中已经讲过会说话的蛇了，带领亚历山大大帝穿过沙漠。
And you don't know that didn't happen. Yeah, and indeed Scrooge. And indeed Scrooge, right. So, I mean, it could have happened. I'm just pointing that out. It could be either of them or not. Okay. Your final choice, please. The final countdown. No, you can go over.
你又不知道那没有发生过。对，还有斯克鲁奇。还有斯克鲁奇，对吧？所以，我是说，这完全可能发生过。我只是指出这一点。它可能是其中任何一个，也可能都不是。好吧。请给出你的最终选择。最后的倒计时。不，你可以超时。
You can go over. We'll cut out all your earlier stuff. Okay, thanks. Anyway, so, okay. I'm worried that this might be a bit of an anti-climax now, but anyway. So Christmas. No, I don't think so. Okay.
你可以超时。我们会把前面那些废话都剪掉的。好的，谢谢。总之，好吧。我担心这现在可能会有点虎头蛇尾，不过不管怎样。所以圣诞节。不，我不这么觉得。好吧。
So Christmas, it's all about the birth of Christ. Okay? Okay. Yeah. Controversial, but yes. Hard-hitting religious punditry. It's like a sermon by a Church of England vicar. Okay, so scenes from the Nativity,
所以圣诞节，一切都关乎基督的诞生。对吧？对。虽然有点争议，但确实如此。犀利的宗教评论。这就像是一个英国国教牧师的布道。好吧，所以关于耶稣降生的场景，
the appearance of the angels and the shepherds, the adoration of the Magi, the Magi's dream, Joseph's dream, the flight into Egypt, the massacre of the innocents, they are daubed onto walls all over England and Wales. So my first big shout-out, because I like to do a church shout-out, is to St. Alien's Hanalien, Hanalien and Ross in Denbighshire. over England and Wales. So my first big shout out, because I like to do a church shout out,
天使和牧羊人的显现、三王来朝、三王的梦、约瑟的梦、逃往埃及、屠杀无辜婴儿，这些都被涂抹在英格兰和威尔士各地的墙壁上。所以我的第一个大声呐喊——因为我喜欢为某个教堂摇旗呐喊——献给登比郡哈纳利安的圣阿利安教堂。遍布英格兰和威尔士。所以我的第一个大声呐喊——因为我喜欢为某个教堂摇旗呐喊——
is to St. Alien's, Hanalien, Hanalien and Ross in Denbighshire. Now, this is a, no, this is a really cool church. Everybody should go there.
献给登比郡哈纳利安的圣阿利安教堂。现在，这是一座……不，这是一座非常酷的教堂。每个人都应该去那儿看看。
It's got these painted panel ceilings. So it's got the adoration of the Magi. It's got the Magi's dream, but it's got all of these painted, medieval painted saints kind of all over the ceiling, painted onto timber absolutely brilliant i have a song oh hey great great well i was wondering if you would have a song well just
它有彩绘的木板天花板。所以上面有三王来朝。有三王的梦境，但天花板上到处都是这种彩绘的中世纪彩绘圣徒，画在木头上，绝对太棒了。我有一首歌，哦，太好了，太好了。其实我想问你有没有准备一首歌，好吧，就
because you know anyway i'll just get straight to it so the church is saint alien's clenalian okay yeah and it goes like this oh i'm clenalian i'm clunalian. I'm Clunalian church. I'm an old church in Denbighshire. Oh, I'm Clunalian. And it goes on like that. That's brilliant. That's brilliant. I can't believe it.
因为你知道的，不管怎样，我直接切入正题吧，所以这座教堂是圣阿利安克伦阿利安，好吧，嗯，它是这样的：哦，我是克伦阿利安，我是克伦阿利安。我是克伦阿利安教堂。我是登比郡的一座老教堂。哦，我是克伦阿利安。它差不多就是这样的。太棒了。太棒了。我真不敢相信。
I can't believe it's Christmas churches, the 23. Okay, fine. But if you want to see kind of holy infancy nativity type scenes on churches, you should definitely go to churches at
我真不敢相信这是圣诞教堂，第23座。好吧，行。但如果你想在教堂里看那种圣婴、圣诞场景，你绝对应该去
Ashamstead in Berkshire, Tornamparva in Suffolk, sorry, Pinvin in Worcestershire, Newington in Kent. But my, and those are all kind of 13th, 14th century paintings. A personal favourite again is in Oxfordshire. Dominic, only down the road
伯克郡的阿沙姆斯特德，萨福克郡的托纳姆帕瓦，抱歉，伍斯特郡的平温，肯特郡的纽宁顿。但是我的，这些基本上都是13、14世纪的壁画。我个人另一个偏爱的地方在牛津郡。多米尼克，就在
from you. You haven't been to see it. It's in Peter's at Vincula, South Newington in Oxfordshire. Oh, I know South Newington. Yeah. Yeah, you drive past it. Have you been to the church though? Yeah, I've never been to the church. I never stopped a car. Exactly. You know the garage. Yeah, exactly. It's on the way to Banbury. It's on the way to Banbury. That stopped exactly you know the garage yeah exactly it's on the way to banbury it's on the way to banbury that's exactly it yeah yeah but this you everybody
你附近。你还没去看过呢。它在牛津郡南纽宁顿的圣彼得教堂。哦，我知道南纽宁顿。对。对，你开车会路过它。不过你去过那个教堂吗？对，我从来没去过那个教堂。我从没停下车过。没错。你知道那个车库。对，没错。它在去班布里的路上。它在去班布里的路上。停下来了，没错，你知道那个车库，对，没错，它在去班布里的路上，它在去班布里的路上，就是这样，对，对，但是这个，每个人
should stop there because it is like it is an amazing church um brilliant because you can always get in which is always a bonus and but in terms of nativity scenes it's got um like a real kind of cartoon strip along the um the north wall of the arcade in the nave uh but what's really great about it is it was painted with oil paints in the 1300s so the colors are really rich and saturated so unlike the kind of clay ochre paints that are quite faded everywhere else i mean the colours just like pop off the walls. And there's, you know, you've got a lovely little flight into Egypt where you've got Mary on a donkey and stuff like that. But the most famous thing there isn't actually a church,
都应该在那里停一下，因为它就像，这是一座令人惊叹的教堂，嗯，太棒了，因为你总能进去，这始终是一个加分项，但就圣诞场景而言，它拥有，呃，就像中殿拱廊北墙上有一条真正的卡通连环画，呃，但它真正厉害的地方在于，它在14世纪是用油画颜料绘制的，所以色彩非常丰富和饱和，因此不像其他地方那些相当褪色的黏土赭石颜料，我是说，这些色彩简直就像从墙上跳出来一样。而且你知道的，那里有一个非常可爱的逃往埃及的场景，玛丽骑在一头驴上之类。但那里最著名的东西其实不是一座教堂，
but you should church. It is a church. The most famous thing in that church is not a Christmas scene, but it's the martyrdom of Thomas Beckett. And it's huge and it's amazing. So how did that survive? I suppose they were just all painted over.
但你该去教堂。它是一座教堂。那座教堂里最著名的东西不是圣诞场景，而是托马斯·贝克特的殉道。它巨大无比，而且震撼人心。那么它是怎么保存下来的呢？我想它们只是都被粉刷覆盖了吧。
They just whitewashed it. Yeah. But that is a brilliant chart and definitely should, you should definitely go there. But my top choice for holy infancy scenes this Christmas would be. So number 10. So number 10. The last of the festive list. The last of the festive list.
它们只是被刷了白石灰。对。但那真是一座了不起的教堂，你绝对应该去那里。不过我今年圣诞节对圣婴场景的首选将是。所以第10个。所以第10个。节日清单的最后一个。节日清单的最后一个。
Is. Is St. Bothwell's Hardham and West Sussex. Now, I did give this a shout out in the last one. Dominic, something in a fit. I remember you and St. Bothels has got something on you, clearly. No, it deserves more than just a shout out because this is the place that has some of the earliest wall paintings in the UK. They date from about the 1100s. They were painted over in 1300.
是。西萨塞克斯郡哈达姆的圣博特尔夫教堂。现在，我在上一个节目里确实提到过它。多米尼克，某种狂热。我记得你和圣博特尔夫教堂之间显然有什么过节。不，它值得的不仅仅是一声赞叹，因为这里拥有英国最早的一些壁画。它们的历史可以追溯到1100年代左右。它们在1300年被覆盖了。
So they survived because they weren't. Hold on. Fashion, Dominic. Fashion on why would fashion dominic fashion fashion fashion anyway so um in this little church kind of cars whizzed past nobody knows it's their small little whitewashed church inside in pink and yellow ochre um there are about 15 scenes from the Holy Infancy. You know, I'm not going to list them all, but my favourite is the one of my favourites is the flight into Egypt. You've got Mary on this little gawky donkey and you've got the presentation in the temple where all the urns start toppling. And then you've got the massacre of the innocents. And I mean, I guess what's so brilliant is they're only kind of spectral remains on these walls.
所以它们得以幸存，是因为没有。等等。时尚，多米尼克。时尚，为什么会是时尚，多米尼克，时尚，时尚，时尚……不管怎样，嗯，在这个小教堂里，汽车呼啸而过，没有人知道它的存在，这是一座粉红色和黄色赭石色内饰的小巧白墙教堂，里面大约有15幅关于圣婴的壁画。你知道的，我不会把它们全列出来，但我最喜欢的其中一个是逃往埃及。你看到玛丽骑在这头笨拙的小毛驴上，还有圣殿奉献的场景，所有的骨灰瓮都开始倾倒。然后你还有屠杀无辜婴儿。我的意思是，最棒的地方在于，这些墙上只剩下幽灵般的残迹。
But they're even still there to so wrought with drama and violence. So these babies are held up by their ankles, ready to be beheaded. And there are bodies kind of strewn around the ground. And it's just so gruesome. But as a nice little fact, one thing is, so the walls are, it's all kind of pink and yellow. Those are the kind of colours that they went for. They would have been kind of more kind of golden and red I guess originally but for kind of um things like halos they used a thing called salt green which is uh one of my uh yeah one thing that I like I always mention because I think it's so cool so the salt green is like almost like a lurid kind of acidic green for
但它们依然存在，充满了戏剧性和暴力色彩。所以这些婴儿被抓住脚踝倒提着，准备被斩首。地面上到处都是尸体。这简直太毛骨悚然了。不过作为一个有趣的小冷知识，有一点是，墙壁是，全都是那种粉红色和黄色。那是他们选择的颜色。我想最初它们可能会更偏向金色和红色，但对于像光环这样的东西，他们用了一种叫做盐绿的东西，这是我的，一个我老是提到的小玩意，因为我觉得它太酷了，所以盐绿色几乎就像是一种骇人的、刺鼻的绿色，用来画
the halos and kind of the really important bits and how they made this salt green was they had sheets of copper they smothered them with honey uh they put salt on top of it and they dipped it into a vat of urine for a couple of weeks took it out scrape it all off grind it all up and then you have this lovely bright green paint for kind of all of the most celestial little bits of it so yeah now um so those are my 10 i have a couple more things i'd just like to say very quickly i do yeah okay so one that would have absolutely made the top 10 but it was it was in my other top 10 so i can't i couldn't have it was um saint andrews boynton in east riding of yorkshire so this is the one um where uh the guy william strickland went to america and brought back
光环和一些非常重要的部分，而这种盐绿色的制作方法是，他们准备好铜板，在上面涂满蜂蜜，在上面撒上盐，然后把它浸入一缸尿液中几个星期，拿出来，全部刮下来，磨碎，然后你就得到了这种可爱的亮绿色颜料，用来画所有那些最神圣的小细节，所以，是的，现在，嗯，这就是我的前10名，我还有几件事想非常简短地补充，我确实有，好吧，所以其中一个绝对能进前10名，但它在我的另一个前10名里，所以我不能选它，它是，约克郡东赖丁的博因顿圣安德鲁教堂，这就是那个，呃，威廉·斯特里克兰去美洲并带回了
turkeys and he's got turkeys all over his church. Do you remember that one? Yes. So, I mean, that would obviously be in a top ten of churches, Christmas churches,
火鸡的家伙，他的教堂里到处都是火鸡。你还记得那个吗？记得。所以，我的意思是，那显然会在一个顶级教堂、圣诞教堂的排行榜里，
but it had already been in the other top ten. So, I just want to put it out there. If anybody wants to hear more about that church, please listen to the previous episode. Okay. I really wanted to talk about
但它已经出现在另一个前10名里了。所以，我只是想把它提出来。如果任何人想听到更多关于那座教堂的信息，请收听上一期节目。好吧，我真的很想谈谈
kind of customs like the Marylewd in Wales and the Hoodening Horse in Kent. What are they? Those are things basically where you get like in Wales
威尔士的“玛丽·吕德”（Mary Lude）和肯特郡的“胡丁马”（Hoodening Horse）之类的风俗。那是什么？这些东西基本上就是，比如在威尔士，
the Mary Lude is like it's a horse's skull and it's on a spring and you see like Oh yes, yes. Chases people around the street. Yes, like chasing but singing
玛丽·吕德就像是一个马的头骨，装在一个弹簧上，你可以看到，哦，是的，是的。在街上追赶人们。是的，就像追逐一样，但伴随着歌唱
and kind of jolly and it's supposed to be good luck and she comes to your door. People say that it's like derived of the donkey that Mary went into Bethlehem on. Oh, that's in the Dark is Rising books by Susan Cooper. Yeah, she's brilliant.
而且很欢快，据说这能带来好运，它会来到你的门前。人们说这源于玛丽进入伯利恒时骑的那头毛驴。哦，那在苏珊·库珀的《黑暗正在崛起》系列书里。对，她太棒了。
Actually, Susan Cooper, she's got one scene in The Dark is Rising. The Grey King? The Green Mantle? No, I can't remember which one. Green cover book, really good. But it's Will. It's Will. Will is the main character. And he's... That's the first Dark is Rising, isn't it?
事实上，苏珊·库珀，她在《黑暗正在崛起》里有一个场景。《灰王》？《绿斗篷》？不，我不记得是哪一本了。绿色封面的书，真的很好。但那是威尔。那是威尔。威尔是主角。那是第一本《黑暗正在崛起》，对吧？
It's not Overseer Understood. But actually, there's one scene in that that I really... I was going to try and find as one of the top churches because I think it's so... It's so frightening, actually, because they're in the church and it's like all the demons are bashing on the windows outside the church and they're kind of trapped inside and they're like
不是，过路人，明白了。但事实上，里面有一个场景我真的……我本来想试着把它找出来作为顶级教堂之一，因为我觉得它太……实际上太吓人了，因为他们在教堂里，就像所有的恶魔都在教堂外面的窗户上猛砸，而他们被困在里面，就像是
that's the first that's number two The Dark is Rising The Dark is Rising so oh it's so good and it's so scary yeah that's set in the Chilterns
那是第一本，那是第二本。《黑暗正在崛起》《黑暗正在崛起》所以，哦，太棒了，而且太吓人了，是的，那是以为奇尔特恩斯为背景的
isn't it yeah yes so anyway but this Mary Lou to the Grey Mayor is a kind of a Welsh thing but there are loads of other versions of it all throughout,
对吧？是的，所以无论如何，但这个玛丽·吕德或灰色母马是一种威尔士的风俗，但在整个
kind of really all throughout England. So there's a hoodning horse in Kent, which again is where they used like sometimes a wooden head, sometimes a horse's head that was decorated, that kind of went around in the Cotswolds, there's a thing called the broad, where they use a decorated bull's head. In the East Midlands, they use a goat's head and
英格兰各地，还有许多其他版本的风俗。所以肯特郡有胡丁马，同样地，有时他们会用一个木制的头，有时是一个装饰过的马头，在科茨沃尔德，有一种叫做“布罗德”（the broad）的东西，他们会用一个装饰过的公牛头。在东米德兰兹，他们用山羊头，
it was called old top so it's kind of an old tradition and i really wanted to try this one in salisbury is there yeah you used to go around the streets with a giant it's in salisbury museum oh right okay because tom i was trying to find a church connection and i couldn't it's not a church it's a it's a i think they kept it in the guild hall or something so it's nothing to do with the church i'm just i'm just throwing it out there. It's very sinister. No, well, but this is the thing. So just as a kind of, you know, I can't, there isn't a Christmas connection to this,
它被称为“老托普”（old top），所以这是一种古老的传统，我真的很想在索尔兹伯里试试这个，有吗？你以前会在街上带着一个巨大的……它在索尔兹伯里博物馆里。哦，对，好吧，因为汤姆，我一直在试图找到一个与教堂的联系，但我找不到，它不是一座教堂，它是一个，我想他们把它保存在市政厅或者别的地方，所以它跟教堂一点关系也没有。我只是，我只是随便提一下。它非常阴森。不，好吧，但这就是重点。所以作为一种，你知道的，我不能，这跟圣诞节没有什么联系，
but basically there is a really interesting story about three horses' heads being found in the spire of a church in Northumberland in Elston, St. Cuthbert's. Tom, your friend, St. Cuthbert? Yeah, yeah. Elston near Annick in Northumberland in elsdon st cuthbert's tom your friend st cuthbert yeah yeah els elsdon in in near annick in northumberland and they found these three horses skulls that were arranged kind of into a triangle in this like cavity completely sealed cavity in the top of the spire which is really cool so like kind of some sort of protective sort of thing some people say it's like for um for like resonance or or reverberation
但基本上，有一个非常有趣的故事，在诺森伯兰郡埃尔斯顿的圣库思伯特教堂的尖顶里发现了三个马头。汤姆，你的朋友，圣库思伯特？对，对。诺森伯兰郡阿尼克附近的埃尔斯顿，圣库思伯特教堂，汤姆，你的朋友，圣库思伯特，对，对，埃尔斯顿，在诺森伯兰郡阿尼克附近，他们发现了这三个马的头骨，它们在这个尖顶顶部的某个空腔里排列成三角形，完全密封的空腔，这真的很酷，所以有点像某种保护性的东西，有些人说那是为了，呃，钟声的共鸣或回响之类的，
of the bells or whatever but I don't really see how that would work. No, it's a bit more M.R. James. Yeah, very M.R. James. So there was that. I would say
但我真的不明白这怎么行得通。不，这更像是M.R.詹姆斯的风格。对，非常M.R.詹姆斯的风格。所以有这么回事。我要说的是，
just as a fan of the podcast the St. Cuthbert's episode Tom was one of my favourites. Oh, thank you. Great, how could you? Honestly, do you know Dominic so didn't want to do that.
作为这个播客的粉丝，圣库思伯特那一期，汤姆，是我的最爱之一。哦，谢谢。太好了，你怎么能……老实说，你知道多米尼克当时有多么不想做那一期吗。
He didn't want to do that. Yeah, I'm shocked at that. But you're right it was a brilliant decision't want to do that. He didn't want to do that. I'm shocked at that. But you're right. It was a brilliant decision to do. It was. Have you still not listened to your own
他不想做那一期。是的，我对此感到震惊。但你说得对，这是一个极其出色的决定。他不想做那一期。我对此感到震惊。但你说得对。这是一个极其出色的决定。确实如此。你还是没听过你自己的
episode? Dominic was wrong. I have not listened. Rachel refuses to listen to her own episode, Tom. No, I'd be too embarrassed.
那一期节目吗？多米尼克猜错了。我还没听过。瑞秋拒绝听她自己的那一期节目，汤姆。不，我会觉得太尴尬了。
I'd be too embarrassed. I'd be too embarrassed. But just last thing I wanted to say, again, something that I couldn't fit in and I really want to, but for me this is very
我会觉得太尴尬了。我会觉得太尴尬了。但最后我想说的一点是，同样地，有些内容我塞不进去但我真的很想讲，但对我来说这非常
important and I will tell you why. So I love tinsel. I love tinsel and so tinsel was invented in nuremberg in 1610 and it's derived from this old french word esintel which means to sparkle i can't speak french there is a place in monmouthshire in wales called coombran it's a new town i think you should do a podcast on new towns if you haven't done one already. Good subject. Yeah. Yeah. So I think you should do something on the new towns.
重要，我会告诉你为什么。我喜欢金属亮片。我喜欢金属亮片，所以金属亮片是1610年在纽伦堡发明的，它源于一个古老法语词“esintel”，意思是闪闪发光。我不会说法语。在威尔士蒙茅斯郡有一个地方叫库姆布兰，这是一个新城。我觉得你们如果还没做过的话，应该做一期关于新城的播客。好题材。对。对。所以我觉得你们应该做点关于新城的内容。
But Coombran in Monmouthshire, there's a, it's one, it's the UK's largest tinsel production factory. And I just love the idea of it. I have to say, I just love, I love tinsel. And at the height of their season,
但蒙茅斯郡的库姆布兰，那里有一个，它是英国最大的金属亮片生产工厂。我就是喜欢这个主意。我必须说，我就是喜欢，我喜欢金属亮片。在他们旺季的高峰期，
they produce 656, sorry, I'm doing like a pretty patella can't get my number back 656,000 feet of sparkly you know sparkly stuff it's amazing it was invented in the early
他们生产656,000英尺，抱歉，我有点像帕特ella，脑子转不过弯来，656,000英尺亮晶晶的，你知道的，亮晶晶的东西，这太神奇了，它发明于17世纪
17th century I would not have known that it's probably not very eco-friendly though Rach Tinsall is it? No it's not so basically in the beginning it was real silver and it kind of caught the light of the um the you know the candles and stuff to make it sparkle then uh silver tarnishes so they started to use um a lead which doesn't tarnish but lead's not great you know yeah it kind of poisons you yeah it poisons you exactly yeah um so then lead went out and now
早期。我本来不知道这一点。不过瑞秋，金属亮片可能不是很环保吧？不，它不环保。所以基本上在一开始，它是纯银的，它能折射，呃，你知道的，蜡烛之类的光，让它闪闪发光，然后，呃，银会变黯淡，所以他们开始使用，呃，不会变黯淡的铅，但铅不太好，你知道的，是的，它会使人中毒，是的，它会使人中毒，没错，是的，嗯，所以后来铅被淘汰了，现在
they use like a sort of pvc thing so no it's not great um but i just yeah tinsel makes me happy um i'll remember that on christmas day that's gonna be a christmas present a big bag of tinsel anyway but just to say um this organ so this place in coomber on in monmouthshire they pride themselves actually kind of in an article they say they pride themselves on their pert and bushy products. Oh my God. Which is exactly what you want tinsel to be. It is. Pert and bushy. Cone grown is important to me
他们用某种聚氯乙烯（PVC）材料，所以不，它不是很好，但我就是，是的，金属亮片让我感到快乐，我会在圣诞节那天记住这一点的，那将是一个圣诞礼物，一大袋金属亮片。不管怎样，只是想说，嗯，这个管风琴，所以蒙茅斯郡库姆布兰的这个地方，他们其实很自豪，他们在文章中说，他们为自己生产的饱满且蓬松的产品感到骄傲。天哪。这正是你希望金属亮片具备的特质。确实如此。饱满且蓬松。库姆布兰对我很重要，
because it is where the founder of the Friends of Friendless Churches was where he was born and grew up. What was his name again? Ivor Bulmer Thomas. Fantastic person. You should do a podcast on him. Well, that's a reminder to our listeners that for Christmas, they should all donate money to the Friends of Friendless churches
因为“无依教堂之友”的创始人就是在那里出生并长大的。他叫什么名字来着？艾沃·巴尔默·托马斯。了不起的人。你们应该为他做一个播客。好吧，这也是对我们听众的一个提醒，为了庆祝圣诞节，他们都应该向“无依教堂之友”捐款，
to save some of these churches that you have been talking about. So on that note, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. I shall see you at Christmas. And to our listeners, thank you so much for listening. Have a wonderful, happy and healthy Christmas. Don't follow Tom Holland down the Scrooge Road, the Barhamburg Road. No, follow me down the Scrooge Road because I'll be going out handing turkeys. I should be dancing like Mr. Fezziwig.
以拯救你们一直在讨论的其中一些教堂。借此机会，非常感谢你来到这个播客。我们圣诞节见。对于我们的听众，非常感谢你们的收听。祝大家圣诞快乐、健康。不要跟着汤姆·霍尔顿走上吝啬鬼之路，走巴姆堡之路。不，跟着我走吝啬鬼之路吧，因为我要出去分发火鸡。我要像费齐威格先生那样跳舞。
Yeah. Or Mr. Fozziwig, of course, as some of us know him from The Muppets Christmas Carol. And Dominic, we will actually amazingly be back on Christmas Day. Now this is very exciting, isn't it, Tom? Shall we tell the listeners about this? Yeah, go ahead and tell the listeners. So Tom had this idea.
是的。或者当然也可以是福齐威格先生，正如我们中的一些人从《布偶圣诞颂歌》里所知道的那样。多米尼克，实际上我们令人惊喜地将在圣诞节当天回归。现在这非常令人兴奋，对吧，汤姆？我们要把这件事告诉听众吗？对，尽管告诉听众吧。所以汤姆有这个想法。
I told him it was a terrible idea, but he has prevailed. And I think it's a brilliant idea and you're all going to love it, of doing the 12 Days of Christmas. Doing a podcast every day for one of the 12 days. So we'll be doing them about events or moments
我告诉过他这是一个糟糕的想法，但他坚持了下来。而且我认为这是一个绝妙的主意，你们都会喜欢它的，那就是过“圣诞节的12天”。在12天的每一天里都做一个播客。所以我们将围绕这一天发生的
that happened on this day. And each one of us has chosen. And each one of us has chosen, exactly. So Tom's are all about eunuchs and genital mutilation. No, they're not. No, they're not. The Labour government of the late 70s. You will have to listen to find out whether that is true or not
事件或时刻来制作它们。我们每个人都做了选择。我们每个人都做出了选择，没错。所以汤姆的全是关于太监和生殖器切除的。不，不是的。不，不是的。70年代末的工党政府。你们得听了节目才能知道这是真是假
but we won't be doing um these kind of podcasts until after 12th night and then in the new year we'll be back with uh with the customary two or maybe maybe maybe more depending but uh in the meanwhile have a very very happy christmas have a great new year and we will see you in the new year merry christmas goodbye merry christmas very, very happy Christmas. Have a great new year and we will see you in the new year. Merry Christmas. Goodbye. Merry Christmas. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community,
但我们在第十二夜之前不会做这种播客，然后到了新年，我们会带着惯例的两个，或者可能，可能，可能根据情况更多回归，但与此同时，祝大家圣诞快乐，新年快乐，我们在新年见。圣诞快乐，再见。圣诞快乐，非常非常快乐的圣诞节。祝大家新年快乐，我们在新年见。圣诞快乐。再见。圣诞快乐。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。